Da bin ich
Leute, ich hab mir heute was gekauft
Was wir morgen und am Wochenende einrichten müssen
Das werde ich vielleicht auch in einem YouTube Video verwursten
Da könnt ihr dann Hallo YouTube oder irgendwas spammen
Also nicht jetzt, nicht jetzt, morgen
Wenn wir uns das angucken
Jetzt könnt ihr jetzt auch spammen
Aber das hat jetzt noch keinen Sinn
Und zwar wisst ihr, was ich mir gekauft hab
Ich hab mir ein
Moment
Komm her Kiste
Also als erstes, ich hab mir sogar zwei Sachen
Ich hab mir zwei Sachen geholt
Was sagst du zum Microsoft Ausfall
Ich hab jetzt gar nicht mehr dran nachgeguckt
Was jetzt genau gewesen ist
Also ich hab's mitgekriegt
Teams ging nicht richtig, Azure Services ging teilweise nicht richtig
Also auch Sachen, die man dort gehostet hat
Ging teilweise nicht richtig
Office Outlook und so ging nicht richtig
Ich weiß nicht, woran's gelegen hat
Vielleicht irgendwelche Netzwerk-Routing-Geschichten
Oder so mal wieder
Also ich hab jetzt gar nicht geguckt
Woran's
Letztendlich lag
Aber Microsoft hat geschrieben
Wir may experiencen
Irgendwelche Ausfälle
Und ja, die hab ich, die hab ich experienced
Ja
Ja, also
Wollte euch ja erzählen
Was ich geholt hab
Zwei Sachen, zwei Sachen hab ich geholt
Das eine ist eher allgemein gut für den Stream
Und das zweite ist für Wochenende
Poggers Bastel-Stells
Und zwar
Das erste, was ich mir geholt hab, ist endlich mal eine gescheite Capture-Karte wieder
Nämlich
Eine HD60X von Elgato
Ich hab ja noch zwei Elgatos hier
Also aus den Zeiten
Als wir noch Call of Duty Sponsoring und sowas gemacht haben
Aber die haben halt immer richtig eklig lag
Damals gehabt
Das musste halt noch alles über USB 2 gehen
Und da mussten sie encoden
Und das hat dann irgendwie so 2-3 Sekunden teilweise gedauert
Das konntest du gar nicht richtig benutzen
Alles hier im Stream
Das war Müll
Mr. Moogame, Dankeschön für den Sub
Also ich hab mir eine gescheite Capture-Karte gekauft
Da können wir jetzt alles mögliche auch mal anstöpseln
Und ohne Verzögerung
Benutzen
Aber
Viel besser, was ich mir bestellt hab fürs Wochenende
Wochenende bauen wir nämlich
Linux-Linux-Emulator
Also, nein, nein, nein, wir bauen keinen Emulator
Linux emulieren kann
Wir bauen eine Konsolen-Emulator-Kiste
Und zwar, ich hab mir was bestellt
Das Video letztens
Hat mich inspiriert
Und zwar, ich hab mir natürlich mal wieder
Was Gescheites bestellt
Und zwar
Einen
Wobei, bringt ja nichts mehr nicht
Wenn ich euch das sage, ich zeig's euch einfach mal
Und zwar hab ich mir bestellt ein
Müssen wir mal kurz hier aufmachen
Ein Mini-Forums
UM690
So ein Teil hab ich mir bestell-
Äh
Das ist das falsche, was hier ausgewählt wurde
So einen hab ich mir bestellt
Ein UM690 32G RAM, 512 GB Festplatte
Und da kommt dann
Äh, Linux drauf mit allen möglichen Emulatoren
Selbstverständlich im Stream
Natürlich nur
Original selbst gerippte
Xbox, Wii
Und Gamecube-Spiele
Versteht sich ja von selbst
So, und das Ding ist
Mega nice, ich hab mir nen Test angeguckt
Kann euch
Wir können uns, wir können uns, nicht Amazon, alter
Äh, wir können uns theoretisch auch ein Video angucken
Äh, Retro Gaming
Das da
Das hab ich mir vorher angeguckt
Und da kam das
Da kam das richtig gut bei weg
Also es sind drinne
Kann euch mal vorlesen, was da hinten drauf steht
Das ist ein
Mini-Forum UM690
Mini-PC 32 GB RAM
512 GB SSD
M2 SSD
Äh, ein AMD Ryzen 9
6900HX
Das ist mit integrierter Grafikkarte
Und die ist gar nicht mal so schlecht
Damit kann man sogar PC-Games
Halbwegs neue PC-Games
In ganz guter Quali spielen
Was ich auf dem Fernsehen nicht machen will, aber
Es ist halt schön klein und kompakt
Es hat ungefähr die Größe von einem Xbox-Controller, das Ding
Sieht jetzt hier so groß aus, ist es nicht
Über die Größe vom Xbox, also Breite
Von einem Xbox-Controller und oben und unten steht es ein bisschen ab
Und da installieren wir dann Linux drauf
Und probieren mal
Emulator-Stells aus am Wochenende
Mal gucken, ob das taugt
Bin ich, da bin ich echt mal gespannt
Ja, ja, Mitte Januar
Also ich habe es mir bei Amazon bestellt
Amazon hat wieder richtig gebatet
Wenn man nämlich bei Amazon danach sucht, findet man nichts richtig
Da findet man
Guckt euch mal an, 0
Da findet man dann Dinger für 999 Euro
Was gebatet ist
Was richtig krasser gebatet ist
Weil
Hier
Ich weiß nicht, warum die es so dämlich gemacht haben
Also anstatt
Dass sie das einfach 150 Euro billiger
gemacht hätten
Gibt es einen 150 Euro Gutschein
Total weirdchamp
Das sieht halt keiner, jeder denkt sich
Fuck ist das teuer, das kaufe ich nicht
Aber es kostet halt im Prinzip das gleiche wie im Shop
Und ist noch lieferbar
Ja
Du hast dein HM90, ja die Dinger sollen wirklich ganz gut
Der HM90 habe ich auch überlegt
Weil der eine dedizierte Grafikkarte hat
Aber es nimmt sich im Endeffekt für die Plattform
Die ich emulieren will gar nicht so viel
Der ist größer
Also was ich drauf machen will ist eindeutig Super Nintendo
N64
Vielleicht ein bisschen PS1
Und PS2
Das weiß ich jetzt nicht so
Was ist da
Was mich da interessiert
Ich meine PS1 und PS2 dürfte den größten Spielekanalog
Auf der Welt haben
Also den es jemals gegeben hat
Ich glaube PS2 ist bis heute noch die meistverkaufte Konsole
Vor allem will ich Wii
Emulieren
Und theoretisch kann man auch Switch drauf emulieren
Soll angeblich auch ganz gut laufen
Muss ich mal ausprobieren
Und Gamecube
Also hauptsächlich ehrlich gesagt
Älteres Nintendo Zeug
Weil ich unter anderem immer so doof war
Ich habe ja mein N64 und meine Wii damals weggeschmissen
Beim Umzug
Außer die Games die habe ich noch
Ohne Witz die Games habe ich wirklich noch
Games genauso wie ich die ganzen Xbox Games noch habe
Aber ganz davon abgesehen
Ähm
Will die ganzen Konsolen eigentlich keiner ins Wohnzimmer stellen
Ja da bin ich mal gespannt
Und die Plattform ist wirklich nice
Wir gehen hier mal ein bisschen vor
Also
Man kann
Man kann hier rauf sogar
Guckt euch das mal an
Man kann hier drauf
Sogar mit Upscaling
Mit Upscaling kann man 3DS und Wii Spiele laufen lassen
Und
Und sogar Wii U Games
Gut Breath of the Wild will ich da drauf nicht spielen
Aber
Ich meine das läuft alles relativ gut
Und das ist Upscaling
Und das Geld auf 180p
Wie gesagt Wii U Spiele bin ich eh nicht so schaft drauf
Eine Wii U habe ich sogar noch irgendwo
Bei mir hört es bei
Bei mir wird es wahrscheinlich bei Wii Spielen auf
Aber ist schon nice
Das Ding läuft garantiert
Flüssiger
Als auf der Switch
Okay das neue Pokémon weiß ich nicht
Aber ältere Pokémon sehen besser aus wahrscheinlich
Als das neue und laufen dort flüssiger
Weil Nintendo sich überhaupt keine Mühe mehr gibt
Für die Games
Dort basteln wir nämlich weiter
Pog
Guck mal wie schnell das jetzt mit M2 SSD geht
Flutscht richtig
Gachibuzz
Ja da werden wir uns am Wochenende ein bisschen dran
Ich muss mal ein bisschen zu machen
Hier ist
Wie viel
Da werden wir uns am Wochenende
Ja genau exakt
Ach das heute Command ist gar nicht mehr drin
Das heute Command vom letzten Mal hätte gut gepasst
Das wir an unserem
Kiste weiter
Basteln
Und sie weiter hübsch machen
Kannst du einen
Staubsauger empfehlen
Ne nicht wirklich ich habe einen Roborock S5
Den ich nicht mehr verwende
Wenn überhaupt würde ich mir einen holen mit Absaugstation
Aber
Die neuen Roborock Dinger funktionieren
Zwar noch aber
Oder wieder wieder muss man sagen
Die neuen Roborock Dinger funktionieren wieder
Allerdings musst du die aufmachen
Moin Patrick
Also das ist doof
Du was du kaufen kannst sind diese
Dreamy Dinger glaube
Aber da habe ich keine Erfahrung
Mit
Nightbot nicht im Chat Nightbot broken
Nice
Ja da basteln wir auch noch ein bisschen dran rum
Da basteln wir auch noch ein bisschen dran rum
Muss mal gucken
Kannst du mir einen Lilux Destroyer empfehlen
Ich würde sagen
Ja aber
Dir bleibt eigentlich nur noch Gentoo übrig oder?
Der Rest ist doch zu easy mode
Da muss erstmal
Zwei Stunden kompiliert werden um den
Oh ich kann ja nicht mehr reden Alter
Da muss erstmal zwei Stunden kompiliert werden
Um den E-Mail Anhang zu öffnen
Ich hatte mal einen Kollege auf der Arbeit
Der hatte
Gentoo
Und der hat das Ding irgendwie am Anfang
Dreimal neu kompiliert den Kernel
Bis die VM seine Netzwerkkarte unterstützt hat
Das er Zeug nachladen kann
Alter man kanns irgendwie auch übertreiben
Archlinux
Ja das wissen wir alle
Das ist eigentlich schon gar nicht mehr erwähnenswert
Das ist default by the way Arch
Ehrlich gesagt
Ich hab Gentoo auch noch nie richtig verwendet
Ich hab auch überhaupt keinen Bock mich mit
Gentoo zu beschäftigen weil ich seh den Vorteil
Von mir überhaupt also den Vorteil überhaupt nicht
Drinnen
Irgendwie
Warum sollte ich das selbst kompilieren
Ich mein bei Arch kannst du aus User Repos auch relativ viel
Kompilieren aber warum also versteh ich nicht
Ja
Das funktioniert aber nicht
Battlesheep das funktioniert nicht
Glaub mir ich hab mir alle schon angeguckt
Das funktioniert nicht
Weißt du warum es nicht funktioniert
Weil das keine Mobile Notifications unterstützt
An sich wär das
Augen das ist viel zu hell
Das kann keine Mobile Notifications
Das kann man ja getrennt ausprobieren
Den Package Manager und das OS
Ja hab ich
Ne nicht mal Bluetooth Dongle
Mit meinem Onboard Bluetooth
Hab ich die Dinger geflasht
Nicht vom Raspberry Pi aus
Vom Desktop PC aus
Ging besser
Die Musik eskaliert wieder voll
Wupp wupp wupp wupp
Du willst Mobile Anwendungen entwickeln
Dann good luck have fun
Also ich würd ja wenn ich
Mobile Anwendungen basteln müsste würd ich
Wahrscheinlich irgendwie was Richtung Ionic machen
Aber
Nur vom Hörensagen ich hab damit noch nix
Gemacht das alles was ich bisher gesehen hab hat mich
Davon am meisten angesprochen
Ja
Ja ich weiß der Rest ist wirklich
Nice ich würd's auch verwenden
Ich will aber Mobile Notifications
Für To Do's und sowas haben
Jetzt vergess ich noch was
Wenn ich denn mal Notifications hab dann
So wir machen mal kurz ein Update
Was
Wär nicht installiert
Es
Eine Runde updaten
Wenn ich jetzt noch richtig tippen könnte
Das wär natürlich richtig
Ein bisschen Poggers
Einmal updaten und dann geht's weiter
Wir basteln heute noch ein bisschen weiter
An unserer neuen Linux VM
Beziehungsweise an unserem
Arch by the way Linux
Wupp wupp wupp wupp
Die Musik eskaliert mir zu sehr
Und weil das
Sehr catchy Soundtrack ist den lass ich übrigens
Während ich arbeite
Sehr gerne nebenbei laufen
Das ist ein absolut Poggers Soundtrack
Aber jetzt ist es mir zu anstrengend
Aber so
Okay also wo sind wir stehen geblieben
Ja wie gesagt ich find's auch
Ich würde prinzipiell ja Obsidian verwenden
Nicht nur weil es eine saumäßig große Community
Mittlerweile hat
Mir fehlt einfach Taskmanagement und Mobile Notifications
Da gibt's ja schon lange
Bei denen PR
Kein PR so ein Feature Request
Wenn die das einbauen
Dann aber das ist schon seit
Zwo Jahren offen
Dann wär ich dabei
Was mich da auch ein bisschen stört ist dass es eben
Nicht Open Source ist
Wobei ich sagen muss
Wenn die was abziehen würden
Das hätte man wahrscheinlich schon gemerkt
Das ist jetzt kein Ausschlusskriterium
An der Stelle
Wie nenn ich hier Richard Stallman
Wenn das nicht Open Source ist
Jetzt mal ne blöde Frage
Wie können die
Wie können die Pull Requests
Haben
Wie können die Pull Requests haben
Ohne das es den Source Code dafür gibt
Oder sind das die Plugins
Nee das ist die Plugin
Das ist die Plugin Liste
Achso
Na dann
Das ergibt natürlich Sinn
Also wir hatten ja einmal Android Studio installiert
Im Stream
Also mit dem Emulator
Ging das eigentlich easy
Aber ich hab ja kein Gerät dazu
Connected
Achso
Nix zum updaten
Wir rebooten mal kurz
Wir sind auf Debian 11
Upgraden wir Paintschamp
Okay da sind jetzt zwei Versionen
Aber normalerweise sind Debian Upgrades
Relativ easy
Es sei denn die Version ist neuer
Und an der Config hat sich was geändert
Will man dann
Eher nicht on the fly live machen
So als erstes
Muss ich jetzt mal was umstellen
Was mich extrem triggert
Jedes mal wenn ich es sehe
Und zwar ich muss die Notification Bar 1 größer machen
Ich keine Lücken mehr zwischen den Blöcken
Hab sonst drehe ich durch
Nix hat es zerrissen
Ja das kommt natürlich vor
So wir brauchen noch einen ordentlichen Font
Für unseren Launcher
Toll ich bin immer noch ein bisschen hin und her gerissen
Und zwar
Was ich für einen Launcher verwenden soll
Ich hatte mir jetzt mal
Offstream U
Launcher hieß das Ding angeguckt
So
U Launcher ist von der Idee her
Eigentlich ganz cool
Also da kann man
Ich stell mal kurz um
Elementary Dark will ich haben
So
U Launcher ist von der Idee her eigentlich ganz cool
Aber
Es gibt ein paar Sachen die mich nerven
Also wofür das da ist
Ich kann es euch mal kurz zeigen
U Launcher
Da kann man jetzt zum Beispiel Anwendungen drüber starten
Drückt man einfach einen Shortcut
Und sagt dann Firefox
Ist im Prinzip eine schönere Variante von Umenu
Nur das es halt mit Plugins erweiterbar ist
An sich ist das eigentlich eine ganz coole Geschichte
Auch das du direkt Google Search aufmachen kannst
Ist eigentlich ganz nice das Ding
Aber
So ein paar Sachen nerven mich
Zum Beispiel
Zum Beispiel das es manchmal einfach zu geht
Ja das habe ich auch schon
Obwohl ich manchmal drinnen bin
Denkt ihr ich bin draußen
Also es gibt Plugins
Das ist schon mal an sich eine coole Geschichte
Zum Beispiel gibt es hier U Launcher
Clipboard Plugin
Ich mag ja Software die du mit Plugins erweitern kannst
Da kann man nämlich selbst sich dran austoben
Nehmen wir das jetzt mal
So und jetzt kann man das starten
Dann sagt man C
Ich kopiere mal kurz ein paar Sachen
Dann öffnet man das
Und dann sagt man C
Und dann hat man hier eben seine Clipboard
Clipboard History
Manchmal und das ist auch
Wie gesagt ich habe das Offstream schon ein bisschen
Ihr habt es gesehen
Jetzt hat es wieder nicht gefressen
Gucken wir mal ob es jetzt
Ob es jetzt hat
Ne jetzt hat er wieder keinen Bock mehr
Also manchmal
Funktioniert das einfach nicht
Manchmal funktioniert es einfach nicht
Wahrscheinlich ist es
Guck jetzt ist es wieder zuge...
Wahrscheinlich ist die Extension jetzt gecrashed
Keine Ahnung
Also irgendwie habe ich ein Problem das manchmal
Der in diesem
Max23 schon ok
Das der manchmal die Clipboard Änderung nicht mitbekommt
Das ist schon ein bisschen doof
Warte mal
Jetzt habe ich dem Menü dem Menü gelauncht
Das ist natürlich auch sehr schlau
Funktioniert aus irgendwelchen Gründen wieder nicht
Weiß nicht
Irgendwas mit Clipboard abgekackt
So aber ich habe
U-Launcher werde ich an sich
Irgendwie nicht so hundertprozentig warm mit
Wie gesagt ich finde es cool das man das erweitern kann
Aber mir gefällt beispielsweise der Clipboard
Das Clipboard Manager Plugin nicht
Erstens ist es extrem lahm
Ich habe mal just for fun
Ein paar Sachen da rein kopiert
Also wenn man z.B. sagt yes
Head-N993
Also wir machen jetzt einfach mal
9999 Zeilen
Wo J drinne steht
Nein nicht J, Y
Fast so schnell wie W
Und wenn man das jetzt mal
Sagen wir xClip
Ja xClip ist noch einmal drauf
Haben wir denn
Die anderen Sachen wenigstens drauf
Ja
So xClip
Was ist was
Was
Minus Selection
Yes
xClip
Und jetzt haben wir das ganze
In der Zwischenablage
Und wenn ich das Ding jetzt dazu überreden könnte
Mal
Zu funktionieren
Dann würdet ihr sehen das es mega langsam wird
Wenn man viele und längere
Einträge im Clipboard hat
Ist ja was
Ich start den Krempel einfach nochmal neu
Hi Max
Ich habe eine Frage
Wie viel kostet ein PC
Gut wichtig das man das abkürzen kann
Und etwas unzufrieden mit meiner Bezahlung momentan
Jetzt bietet mein Unternehmen
Allen BCs an Schulungen zu machen
An denen mein Interesse hat die Schulung
Kosten 30 bis
Du meinst jetzt wahrscheinlich
Du meinst 4k
Nicht 4000k
Weil 4000k ist ein bisschen viel
Das würde ich auf jeden Fall nehmen
3 bis 4000 Euro inklusive Zeit
Die Schulung würde ich gerne mitnehmen
Aber es wäre mir ein schlechtes Arbeitszeug gegeben
Falls ich 1 bis 2 Monate
Das dürfen die gar nicht
Immer unabhängig davon das sie es vielleicht versuchen können
Mal ganz davon abgesehen
Wenn ein Unternehmen nicht das an irgendwelche Bedingungen knüpft
Es kommt ja manchmal so
Es gibt ja manchmal so Schulungsprogramme
Das die sagen okay
Wir machen jetzt irgendwie Schulungsoffensive
Und dann müssen die Leute sich allerdings
Nochmal irgendwie ein Jahr weiter verpflichten
Aber wenn die das nicht machen
Dann können die sich auch nicht beschweren dass du nachher kündigst
Und sie dürfen dir gar kein schlechtes Arbeitszeugnis ausstellen
Dann kannst du ja auch sagen
Das entspricht überhaupt nicht meinen Aufgaben
Und wenn sie nicht damit klarkommen dass die Leute kündigen
Da sind sie selber dran schuld
Also ganz im Ernst ich gehe davon aus
Die stellen nämlich mal ein schlechtes Arbeitszeugnis aus
Also man kann ja zumindest mal
So einen halbwegs professionellen Ablauf erwarten
Und
Das ist es auch noch nicht ein Arbeitszeugnis auszustellen
Also ich kenne jetzt den Laden natürlich nicht
Keine Ahnung
Kann natürlich auch sein dass es richtige Dreckssäcke sind
Aber ich würde jetzt erstmal standardmäßig erwarten dass die sich
Ordentlich verhalten
Ja
Wenn es natürlich daran jetzt die Chance gibt
Dass du noch mehr Geld kriegst dann
Arbeitszeugnisse müssen wohlwollend sein
Das heißt nicht das die wohlwollend
Geschrieben sein müssen
Das heißt das die wohlwollend formuliert sein müssen
Allerdings du kannst auch ein wohlwollend
Formuliertes Zeugnis machen
Und du darfst da nichts negatives reinschreiben
Und das ist ja auch da
Das es sich gut anhört
Und jemand der es kennt weiß das es nicht gut gemeint ist
Ja also
Ich würde erwarten die schreiben dir ein ordentliches Zeugnis
So wie es eben
Den Tatsachen entspricht
Und wenn sie das nicht machen
Beschwerst du dich einfach
Und sagst das Zeugnis so geht das nicht
Ich würde jetzt aber gar nicht von ausgehen dass die
Standardmäßig da irgendwie dir was reinwürgen wollen
Weil die haben da eigentlich überhaupt kein Interesse dran
Es wäre sogar aus heutiger Sicht
Total blöd sich für die Zukunft
Mit jemand zu verkacken
Weil wer weiß du kommst ja mal wieder
Kann ja alles sein
Ob es U-Launcher jetzt hinbekommen hat
Ich sollte mal U-Launcher hier eintragen
Oder
U-Launcher
Wenn ich das auch richtig schreiben kann
So
Waren wir da noch
R Zeichen davor
Und dann starten wir das nochmal neu
Jetzt gucken wir mal ob das alles startet
Und dann können wir weiter machen
Genau das denke ich mir auch
Wenn die keine weiteren Bedingungen daran knüpfen
Also bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber
Wo ich die Ausbildung gemacht habe
Ihr wisst ja habe ich ja schon
Mehrere Videos drüber gemacht
Da gab es ja bei den Provider da gab es ja Probleme
Und unter anderem
Haben die irgendwann auch angefangen
So Schulungsprogramme raus zu hauen
Allerdings mit
Ganz ganz merkwürdigen Bedingungen
Also erstens solltest du dich ewig
Zeiten dran binden an den Arbeitgeber
Ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher wie lang es gewesen ist
Es könnten sogar
Fünf Jahre gewesen sein
Oder sowas total weltfremd
Es war auf jeden Fall viel zu viel
Es war total wir
Wahrscheinlich rechtlich fraglich ob es überhaupt zulässig ist
Und
Die Schulungen waren auch
Willkürlich ausgesucht für die Leute
Man konnte sich die Schulungen nicht selbst aussuchen
Und dann wollten sie noch das du die Schulungen teilweise am Samstag machst
Die hatten komplett den Arsch offen
Ich habe das nicht unterschrieben und ich würde es auch keinem empfehlen
Sowas zu unterschreiben
Da habe ich ein Video drüber gemacht ja
Okay ich glaube
Ich glaube jetzt
Jetzt hat es EU Launcher gepackt
Das man
Das Copy-Pasten ordentlich funktioniert
Ja
Jetzt funktioniert Copy-Pasten
So yes
Aha
Xclip
Wie wie wie
Minus I Primary und Selection
Genau das würde ich haben
Und
Meinetwegen auch noch falls es das gibt
Achso das geht nicht
Fügt man da was ein
Ernsthaft ist das wieder so kompliziert
Einfach was ins Clipboard zu zu bringen
So
Wenn man da ein paar Sachen drin hat wird das übertrieben langsam
Also
Ich hatte Performance Probleme mit EU Launcher
Und
Mir hat auch mir hat auch generell dieses dieses Menü hier nicht gefallen
Und ich habe direkt einen Bug gefunden Leute
Passt mal auf
Echo
Span
Ähm
Was muss man da machen hier wie Color
Oh Leute ich brauche CSS
Kann man einfach Color Blue machen
Ne Moment Moment
Style
Und jetzt Color Blue
Geht das so und dann
Und ich habe einen Bug gefunden
Guck mal
Der escaped
Das Ding escaped HTML irgendwie nicht richtig
Und wenn man Pech hat
Und macht es Multiline
Dann hast du teilweise in einem Clipboard
Einen super großen blauen Text und sowas drinnen
Also
Das ist irgendwie nicht der Weisheits letzter Schluss
Ich
Ich bin damit nicht so ganz glücklich geworden
Die Plugins an sich
Sind cool
Wer braucht sowas
Clipboard Manager
Jeder braucht einen Clipboard Manager
Problem ist nur wenn du jetzt sagst
HTML
Example
Problem ist jetzt
Wenn du jetzt sowas hier zum Beispiel
HTML Zeug reinkopieren
Hä
Du copy pastest halt Sachen
Da kann doch auch mal HTML drinnen sein
Ich würde mich eher fragen
Wer nicht ab und zu mal HTML
Copy pastet
Ich meine wenn du irgendwelche Frontend Sachen entwickelst
Du pastest laufend irgendwelche HTML Geschichten
Manchmal gehts
Manchmal gehts auch nicht
Also manchmal mag er nicht
Ja und jetzt funktioniert das nicht so gut
Funktioniert es wieder
Ich habe nicht ganz rausgekriegt wann es nicht funktioniert
Zumindest gab es noch ein paar mehr Punkte
Ähm
Was mich auch
Was mich auch persönlich gestört hat ist
Das man den U-Launcher
Das man das Copy Menü nicht direkt aufmachen kann
Weil ich benutze den Clipboard Manager
Also ich kann es euch ja mal zeigen
Auf der anderen Kiste
Auf der alten Kiste
Also ich habe mir das Ding
Die letzten zwei Tage mal angeguckt
Ich glaube für mich ist das
Nichts
Und zwar
Aha Bing Image of the Day
Alles klar
So und zwar
Normalerweise benutze ich ja meinen Clipboard Manager total oft
Ja ich mache dann hier off
Paste die irgendwas rein
Auf next sowieso
Es geht sogar so weit
Das wenn ich Sachen von einem Fenster ins andere kopieren muss
Dann kopiere ich erstmal
Drei vier Dinger
Und dann füge ich die woanders mit dem Clipboard Manager wieder ein
Und ihr seht schon wie schnell das aufgeht
Ich kann direkt
Ich drücke eine Taste Bäm und das ist auf
Und
Das ist beim
Das ist beim U-Launcher nicht so
Beim U-Launcher muss ich immer den Shortcut drücken
C Leerzeichen
Und dann warten bis es lädt
Man kann das ganze natürlich ein bisschen skripten
Ich könnte jetzt sagen U-Launcher
Toggle
Äh und und Sleep
Oder so
Und Type C
Ja das könnte ich machen
Und dann würde es das automatisch aufmachen
Aber das ist
Trotzdem lahm
Ich will eine Taste
Ich will eine Taste drücken
Das direkt mein Menü aufgeht
Dafür hat es andere relativ coole Plugins
Wir können uns ja mal kurz
Tensions
Dafür hat es ganz coole Plugins
Die man
Vieles schon
Schon von Haus aus bekommt
Man bekommt ein Imoji
Ne
Can this thing
Is
Oh, Disable Cache.
Okay, die Seite ist gerade broken.
Die Seite ist gerade...
Also es gibt einen Emoji-Picker, einen Clip-Porting.
Also es gibt viele Add-Ons.
Aber was mich persönlich nervt, ist, dass man alles mit Prefix nur starten kann und nicht direkt selbst.
Und, dass es selbst relativ schwierig ist zu erweitern.
Es sei denn, man baut eine Extension.
Es gibt die Möglichkeit, dass man hier in Shortcuts was einträgt.
Das ist aber bloß One-Way.
Also du kannst da nur sagen, Wiki und dann trägst du einen Text an und dann öffnet er das.
Du kannst jetzt nicht zum Beispiel eine Custom...
Da drüber Custom...
Also du kannst jetzt nicht über diese Shortcuts beispielsweise Custom-Text hier reinladen.
Was ich auch ein bisschen doof finde von der Erweiterbarkeit.
Also ich glaube, es wird bei mir doch kein New Launcher.
Sondern, sondern doch...
Sondern doch wieder Rofi werden.
Also ich glaube, es wird wieder...
Das da.
Der sieht zwar standardmäßig ziemlich...
Ziemlich kacke aus.
Also ich meine...
Das Ding sieht standardmäßig ziemlich, ziemlich müllig aus.
Hat noch nicht mal Icons drin.
Aber man kann sich das ja...
Zusammenbauen.
Ich glaube, da werde ich mich jetzt mal ein bisschen dran austoben.
So, dann brauchen wir noch eine andere Sache.
Wir brauchen irgendwas.
Um Notifications zu empfangen.
Und ich würde sagen, dann nehme ich das Allersimpelste, was es geht.
Dann nehme ich den XFCE Notifier.
Und fertig.
Taugt der Clipboard Manager in Windows was?
Ja, der ist ganz okay.
Der ist ganz in Ordnung.
Rofi Teams probiert.
Du meinst das GitHub...
Das da?
Ne, Moment.
Ich weiß, was du meinst.
Dieses mit 4000 Sternen.
Das war mir zu übertrieben.
Du meinst das hier, gell?
Ne.
Dunst sieht kacke aus.
Und außerdem...
Wo brauche ich irgendwas, was Text anzeigen kann und sonst nichts?
Was muss ich denn hier starten dafür überhaupt?
Äh...
Was ist da?
Kann das sein?
Probieren wir mal.
Notify Send Tackle.
Bam, funktioniert.
Nice.
Gibt es da vielleicht auch ein paar...
Ach komm, wir lassen es in der Default-Config.
Ich will ja nicht zu viel dran rumwursten.
Ja.
Das ist doch ganz in Ordnung.
Du hast das erste Mal in F-Sharp programmiert.
Nice.
Habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Ich habe noch nie F-Sharpt.
Wir brauchen jetzt erstmal ein gescheites Farbschema dafür.
Wir editieren mal kurz unsere.
Window Manager Config.
Zum Starten.
Und dann...
Ctrl-D.
So, das können wir schon mal alles rausschmeißen.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
Brauchen wir nicht, brauchen wir nicht, brauchen wir nicht.
Standard-Font ist...
Hack.
Was eigentlich egal ist, weil ich den Font eh überschreibe.
Null.
So, das brauchen wir auch alles nicht.
Können wir lassen.
Mod-D.
Da haben wir noch D-Menü drin.
Das wollen wir nicht.
Wir wollen...
Wir wollen das Show launchen.
Wenn ich jetzt reload...
Und Strg-D drücke...
Das sieht standardmäßig...
Das sieht standardmäßig schon ziemlich, ziemlich paintchampig aus.
Haskell ist einfacher als F-Sharp.
Ich kann weder zu dem einen noch zu dem anderen was sagen.
Das ist das funktionale .NET-Gedöns, richtig.
Ich kann aber, wie gesagt...
Das habe ich noch nie...
Mich ausgesetzt.
In diesem...
Von funktionalen Programmiersprachen habe ich bisher Abstand gehalten.
Das Funktionalste...
Das war wahrscheinlich Rust bisher.
Und Rust ist schon ziemlicher Pain in the Bobbys manchmal.
Auf der Arbeit habe ich mal ein bisschen Erlang gelesen und zwei Zeilen editiert.
Wir hatten mal...
Ich kann nicht mehr, was das war.
War ein Erlang.
Hat nur aus Klammern bestanden.
Doch Elisp!
Ich habe Emacs...
Ich habe Emacs früher selbst konfirmiert mit Elisp.
Das war auch ganz furchtbar abartig.
Du kannst...
Also, ich würde immer mal bei Berrybase gucken.
Berrybase haben doch irgendwie so einen...
Berrybase-Club oder sowas, wo es manchmal welche gibt.
Was ich bei objektorientierter Programmieren nicht ganz hinbekommen ist...
Dateien verarbeiten, verschiedene Typen oder Inhalt.
Hä?
Was hat das jetzt mit OOP zu tun?
Dateien verarbeiten, verschiedene Typen oder Inhalt.
Ich kann dir nicht ganz folgen.
Du machst das alles immer in Funktion.
Das machst du in Objektorientierung ja auch.
Da heißt es halt Methoden.
Aber im Prinzip...
Im Prinzip ist es ja genau das gleiche.
Nur dass du es halt in der Klasse reinschreibst.
Nee, F-Sharp ist genau.
F-Sharp ist nicht...
C-Sharp ist OOP.
Wobei C-Sharp mittlerweile auch einiges Funktionales dabei hat.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Du kannst aber bei Geiz halt einfach mal die Diff...
Die Diff-Seite angucken zwischen den Netzteilen.
Machen wir doch mal einfach.
Komm, wir sind mal nett.
Das hat immer...
Ich habe das Dark Power 13 da, oder?
Habe ich nicht das Dark...
Nee, eigentlich habe ich ein Dark Power 12 drin.
Okay, was denn?
Dark Power 13.
Ah, das ist die ATX3-Variante.
Ah, deswegen ist das so teuer.
Weil es die ATX3-Variante ist wahrscheinlich.
Pure Power 12M.
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Moment, wie addet man das jetzt nochmal?
Adden?
Oh, ich bin zu blöd.
Wie addet man das jetzt nochmal in eine Vergleichsliste?
Nicht zur Vergleichsliste, steht sogar extra da.
Null.
Wir sollten es vielleicht da mal lesen.
So, und was vergleichst du...
Und dann willst du noch das da zum Vergleich.
Und wie macht man...
Hier.
So, jetzt können wir mal gucken, wo der Unterschied ist.
Doch, du kannst auf Geiz halt vergleichen.
Das ist auch ganz gut, weil da kannst du herstellerübergreifend...
Jetzt musst du ja nicht be quiet sein.
So, Lüfter sind unterschiedlich und die Lautstärke ist unterschiedlich.
Das ist aber wahrscheinlich nicht mal so wild, weil die Netzteile meistens nicht sonderlich viel Krach machen.
Preislich dürfte das hier eine ganze Ecke gelistet sind.
So ungefähr gleich alle.
Ja, hätte ich das mal gewusst, dann hätte ich jetzt dann ein ATX3-Netzteil schon reingemacht.
So, aber was ist denn hier der Unterschied?
Hier hast du ein bisschen mehr...
Bisschen mehr...
Ne, du hast SATA drin.
Ah, das ist Titanium.
Titanium, oder?
80, 80 plus, ja, das ist schon mal klar.
Ist das Titanium-Rated und das Gold-Rated, oder was ist denn das?
Ne, Gold...
Doch, ja, das ist Titanium-Rated, das ist Gold-Rated.
Okay, das ist schon mal der eine Grund, warum es teurer ist.
Das macht für dich daheim mit der Kiste wahrscheinlich gar keinen großen Unterschied.
Es macht allgemein keinen großen Unterschied.
Den ausschlaggebendsten Punkt macht es wahrscheinlich, wenn du was ultra-low-power-mäßiges dran betreiben würdest.
Weil dann sind die...
Die sind ja überhaupt nicht effektiv.
Also Netzteile sind in der Regel nie sonderlich effektiv, wenn du sie mit ganz wenig Last betreibst.
Aber wirklich viel...
Also, bis du das Geld gespart hast zwischen Titanium und dem 80 plus Gold,
dann hast du...
Bis du den Netzteilpreis raus hast, das dauert.
So, dann ist es...
Dann ist das andere ein bisschen kleiner.
Bei...
Ne, das ist sogar größer.
Das ist ein bisschen kleiner.
Du hast...
Du kriegst...
Kannst du wirklich ein bisschen mehr...
Ein bisschen mehr...
Hast ein bisschen mehr Ampere.
Kannst insgesamt ein bisschen...
Wobei...
Eigentlich...
Keinen großen Unterschied.
Vielleicht, wenn du super übertakten willst oder so.
Anzahl der 12-Volt-Schienen.
Okay.
Das ist irgendwie so ein Spezialding.
Da habe ich keinen Plan von.
Was uns das genau sagen soll.
Also, ehrlich gesagt...
Ich sehe jetzt nicht großartig einen Unterschied.
Ich sehe jetzt nicht den Unterschied, was den Preis rechtfertigen würde.
Wo steht denn der Preis?
Hier, guck mal.
Also, was die 100...
120-Euro-Unterschied wirklich rechtfertigen würden.
Also, ich habe das hier.
Warum ist meins mega teuer gerade?
Dark Power 12.000.
Warum ist meins, was älter ist, teurer?
Oder so teuer wie das...
Ach so, weil das meins quasi der Vorgänger von dem hier ist.
Verstehe, verstehe.
Also, ganz ehrlich.
Du kannst dir wahrscheinlich auch ohne Probleme das da kaufen.
Wenn es hier um die 100 Euro geht, macht es, glaube ich, keinen großen Unterschied.
Max, willst du die Programmierprüfung erstes Semester in der Uni machen?
Ist das in Java?
In welcher Sprache?
Nee, dann nicht.
Dann bestimmt nicht.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Geh mir weg.
Oh, ich habe was ganz Wichtiges vergessen, Leute.
Wir haben noch keine ordentlich farbige LS-Ausgabe.
Das geht ja nicht.
Das ist das Allerwichtigste, was wir machen müssen.
So.
Farbige LS-Ausgabe.
Viel nicer gleich.
Umso mehr Farben im Terminal, umso besser.
Ich glaube, da sind wir uns einig.
Auf der anderen Seite.
Die klassische LS-Ausgabe hat auch was.
Weil so sieht es halt auf einem Remote-System auch aus.
Dann gewöhnt man sich daran, dass es halt auf einem Remote-System so aussieht.
Also vielleicht lasse ich auch das klassische LS.
Ach, guck mal.
Ich kann ja beides installiert lassen.
So, wir wollten Rofi ein bisschen customizen.
Rofi, Tomorrow, Theme, GitHub.
Erstmal braucht es ein gescheites...
Genau.
Erstmal braucht es ein gescheites Farbschema.
Ohne gescheites Farbschema geht nix.
Obviously.
Was machen die Ausrufezeichen davor?
Das ist doch ein Kommentar, oder?
Ja.
Okay.
Also wir brauchen Farbschema.
Ohne Farbschema.
Tut's nix.
Wo kommen die Rofi-Themes hin?
Local?
Share?
Nee.
Rofi-Theme-Location.
User-Share?
Nee, nee, nee.
Local.
Wo kommen die Dinger hin?
Dort Local.
Nee, ich bin mir relativ sicher.
Ja.
Local-Share.
Dort Local-Share.
Ja.
Local.
Hey.
Wo müssen die Teile denn hin?
Wie wäre es, wenn sowas als erster Google-Treffer vielleicht auftauchen würde?
Westerm hat auch eine Statusbar, die man konfigurieren kann.
Nice.
Kannst du mal einen Link schicken?
Was ist mit der Musik los jetzt?
Leider nicht angenehmer.
Was wollt ihr wissen?
Ach, hier direkt drüber.
Ja.
Statusbar muss man mal suchen.
Set-Ride-Status.
Das da?
Ah, okay.
Na, das ist nicht schlecht.
Also quasi, wenn man nicht alles mit Tabs voll spammt, dann kann man da sich noch was anzeigen lassen.
Na gut, ich habe ja meine Statusbar hier oben.
Ich wusste gar nicht.
Also, das Problem hatte ich in T-Max schon.
Ich wusste gar nicht, was ich da großartig mir anzeigen lassen soll.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Gudeo.
Excellent.
Ich glaube, die Themes müssen nach MKD.
Local Share.
Local Share Rofi oder sowas.
CD, Local Share.
Wget.
So, und jetzt können wir mal gucken, ob das angeboten wird.
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Dann muss es in Themes.
Ich rate jetzt einfach mal.
Man findet ja bei Google nichts Gescheites.
Tomorrow.
Da ist es.
Siehste?
Easy.
So.
Can't read.
No such file or directory.
Ja, ach.
Dann leg es halt an.
Wo ist das Problem, man?
Ey, wieso?
Da ist es doch.
So, und jetzt können wir das ein bisschen customizen, weil ganz im Ernst, so sieht es halt kacke aus.
Ich meine, es gibt Schlimmeres, aber hübsch.
Hübsch.
Hübsch ist nur echt, ist nur echt was anderes.
Es fehlen schon mal die ganzen Modi, die man auswählen kann und, und sonstigen Dingern, also.
So.
Rofi Config Example.
Haben wir da irgendein Beispiel?
Config MD.
Hier.
Paukas.
Excellent.
Zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack.
Ne, das brauchen wir nicht.
Modes.
Okay.
Was wollen wir für Modes haben?
Window Run SSH.
Ne, SSH brauchen wir nicht.
Sollte der nicht eigentlich jetzt alles mögliche anzeigen?
Show?
Sollte ich nicht hier unten jetzt eigentlich eine Leiste haben zum Auswählen?
All die Musik ist mir zu anstrengend.
Ich brauch doch wieder Relaxing.
Wow, wow, wow, wow.
Relaxing Mario.
Oder so.
Ja, auch gut.
Auch wunderbar.
So.
Ah, jetzt.
Sollte der nicht eigentlich die ganzen Modi anzeigen?
Modes?
Wir fangen auf jeden Fall mal nicht mit Window an, sondern mit D-Run und dann Run.
Und dann meinetwegen Window, wobei ich den Windows-Switcher eh nicht verwende.
Okay, gut.
Jetzt können wir nämlich darüber Anwendungen starten.
Zum Beispiel Firefox.
Jetzt brauchen wir noch was mit Icons.
Show Icons True.
Das brauchen wir.
Das ist schon mal viel besser.
Ja, guck mal.
Jetzt sieht's schon mal nicht gar so kacke aus, oder?
Das sieht doch jetzt schon mal besser aus als vorher.
So.
Dann nehmen wir noch so viel Font.
Deswegen hab ich den nämlich installiert.
Weil ich finde, das sieht ganz gut aus.
So, irgendwie Medium 16.
Äh.
Was jetzt?
Ja, das sieht doch jetzt schon mal deutlich besser aus als vorher, oder?
Da kann man doch direkt, kann man sich das doch fast schon geben.
Ach, hier kann man zwischen den Modi umschalten.
Da hätte ich aber gerne einen Button unten, weil ich merke mir doch nicht alle Modi.
Vor allem ist das, was ist das?
Control-Tab.
Da denke ich im Leben nicht dran, dass man Control-Tab und Control...
Äh, Control-Shift-Tab.
Wer zum Teufel kann Control-Shift-Tab drücken?
Ohne sich die Finger zu verbiegen.
Probiert das mal aus, Leute.
Euch tut ja der kleine Finger weh.
Control-Shift-Tab.
Nicht aus Versehen auf Caps Lock kommen.
Das ist zum Geier.
Egal, Default-Tastenbelegung.
Na, Control-Shift-T zum Beispiel für neue Tabs ist ja vollkommen in Ordnung.
Das ist das gleiche wie im Browser.
Also im Browser benutze ich so gut wie nie Control-Shift-T.
Da drücke ich immer T.
Für neuen Tab.
Und Control-Shift-T.
Und Control-Shift-T zum alten Tab wieder aufmachen.
Hallo?
Was?
Aber das brauchst du ja nicht so oft.
Control-Shift-Tab?
Ne.
Control-Shift-Tab kann man ab und zu mal drücken, wenn man einen Tab wieder aufmachen will.
Aber ansonsten...
Irgendjemand hat gesagt...
Dings...
Was?
Minus...
Dump?
Config oder so?
Ne.
Minus?
Was?
Ah!
Ach so!
Aha!
Guck mal.
Guck mal da.
Okay, das ist natürlich praktisch.
Das ist natürlich praktisch.
Dann sieht man, was es gibt.
Dann sieht man, was es an Config gibt.
Können wir uns dann gleich anschauen.
Das ist ganz, ganz nützlich.
Aber sieht jetzt ja schon mal ganz okay aus.
So.
Wir brauchen auf jeden Fall Show-Icons.
Show-Icons.
Ne, haben wir ja.
Icon-Theme-Default ist in Ordnung.
Ähm.
Ja, das ist auch okay.
Können sich wieder nicht entscheiden, wie laut die Musik sein soll.
Kleiner Finger.
Ringfinger.
Mittelfinger.
Ja, so mache ich das auch.
Ich mache...
Ich drücke...
Ich drücke Control-Shift komplett mit dem kleinen Finger.
Und dann drücke ich mit dem...
Mit dem Mittelfinger-Tab.
Aber...
Äh.
Control-Shift-T ist ja in Ordnung.
Das geht ja im Browser easy.
Aber...
Aber Control-Shift-Tab ist...
Eklig.
So.
Was braucht man denn sonst noch?
Macht man das Theme oben?
Oder macht man das Theme unten?
Man macht das bestimmt unten.
Das...
Die Default-Config richtig greift.
Okay.
Das ist eigentlich so in Ordnung.
Ich glaube vielmehr...
So.
Jetzt bin ich gerade noch am überlegen, wie kriegt man das jetzt nochmal hin, dass man unten ein Menü hat.
So zum Auswählen.
Das ist bestimmt so eine Theming-Geschichte.
Gehen wir hier rein?
Was haben wir denn hier?
RGB.
Oh, können wir den Hintergrund transparent machen?
Sack.
Das muss ich mal ausprobieren.
Ob das funktioniert.
Hey, Leute.
Wir können hier...
Transparent Background.
Pogu.
Das Aller...
Das Allerwichtigste.
Das Aller, Allerwichtigste.
Das brauchen wir.
Transparent Background.
Nee, eigentlich...
Eigentlich brauchen wir das nicht.
Das sieht...
Das sieht massiv scheiße aus mit Transparent Background.
Vor allem, wenn wir das hier so aufmachen, dann erkennst du gar nichts.
Nee, das ist nix.
Das wollen wir wieder rückgängig machen.
Das sieht nix aus.
So, was haben wir hier?
Einen Text-Prompt.
Leute, ich frage mich ernsthaft, wie ich da unten...
Ich weiß, das geht.
Man kann hier unten anzeigen lassen, was es für Modi gibt.
Da bin ich aber nicht sicher, ob man das im Theme machen muss.
Oder ob das eine Config-Option ist.
Show Mode Tabs oder irgendwie sowas.
Browser Tab Switching.
Und was?
Firefox Tabs.
Gibt was, um Firefox Tabs zu durchsuchen.
Das ist natürlich porke.
Das brauche ich.
Oh, das ist nice.
Ach, man braucht...
Na, das ist natürlich doof.
Man braucht eine Browser-Extension dafür.
Na gut, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Die Browser haben da wahrscheinlich keine API, irgendwie drauf zuzugreifen.
Aber das ist natürlich...
Das wäre natürlich cool, wenn das geht.
Lacho, danke schön für den Sub.
Das wäre natürlich nice, wenn man damit seine Browser-Tabs filtern könnte.
Hast du...
Wir können auch nochmal ein anderes Cursor-Theme gleich machen.
So.
Gibt es jetzt da irgendwas Sinnvolles, was ich noch machen kann?
Wie mache ich denn die Icons größer?
Einmal kurz checken.
Ich glaube, da muss man irgendwo hier rein.
Was haben wir denn jetzt?
Icon Text.
Icon.
Hier.
Und dann...
So ist die Width oder sowas.
Nope.
Size.
Kann das sein?
80.
Wollen wir mal sagen.
Size 2 EM.
Ah.
Guck mal.
Jetzt.
Noch besser.
Jetzt erkennt man wenigstens richtig was.
Jetzt ist es...
Jetzt ist es vielleicht schon fast ein bisschen zu groß, oder?
Jetzt brauchen wir ein bisschen Spacing.
Space.
Irgendwie jetzt.
Spacing oder 5 Pixel.
Sonst sieht es dumm aus.
Ja.
Und vielleicht nicht ganz so groß.
Vielleicht nicht ganz so groß.
Aber 1,5 EM.
Damit kann ich leben.
Das ist doch vollkommen...
Ey.
Der Text ist nicht richtig aligned.
Igitt.
Darkseid.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Der Text ist nicht richtig aligned.
Hör mal bloß auf.
Aber damit bin ich jetzt erstmal...
Damit kann ich leben.
Das ist okay.
Wunderbar.
Ja, jetzt brauchen wir noch Greenclip als Clipboard Manager dafür.
Dann bin ich glaube ich erstmal zufrieden, so wie das Launcher-Menü ist.
Ähm.
Ging das?
Simple Clipboard Manager.
Ja.
Hier.
Modi.
Das muss man jetzt glaube ich in die E3-Config hauen.
Also quasi das da.
Und das wird jetzt minus P machen.
Und dann sollte mein Clipboard Manager automatisch...
Ups.
Automatisch launchen.
Ja.
Aber der Text ist nicht richtig aligned.
Alter, sieht das hässlich aus.
MonkaS.
Öh.
So, mal ein bisschen anderes Zeug copy-pasten, ob das funktioniert.
Äh.
Okay.
Ah, der andere Krempel läuft noch.
Der U-Launcher-Kram läuft noch.
Okay, dann ist natürlich kein Wunder, dass es nicht funktioniert.
Kurz ausmachen und wieder an.
Moin, Intense Hunter.
So, Menü.
Menü.
So, jetzt mal schauen, ob Copy-Paste funktioniert.
Immer noch nicht.
Warum nicht?
Muss ich Greenclip nochmal von Hand starten?
Vielleicht, dass das funktioniert?
Just.
Just for Head.
Wahrscheinlich muss ich das nochmal von Hand starten.
Komm mal.
Kommen wir mal, ob das funktioniert.
So.
Firefox aufmachen.
Denkst du, aufmachen?
Ah, jetzt.
Jetzt hat er es gecheckt.
Guck.
Lull.
Jetzt geht das alles.
Sehr schön.
Jetzt habe ich auch ein Clipboard-Menü.
Was schnell lädt.
So mag ich das.
Jetzt müssen wir noch nach Config.
Oh, wo war das?
Config Greenclip.
Und dann die Max-History.
9999 Einträge.
Ich brauche History as fuck.
Enable Image Support.
Man konnte noch irgendwie sagen, dass der beides überschreibt.
Sync.
Primary.
Use Primary Selection.
Ah, ne, hat er schon.
Wie oft hast du schon Passwörter geleakt mit dem Clipboard-Manager?
Glaube gar nicht.
Passt da immer auf.
Was natürlich mega nice wäre,
wäre irgendeine Funktion,
dass ich das Clipboard-Disablen könnte.
Also, dass ich beispielsweise sagen könnte,
dass es hier unbedingt ein Icon hat, wo man draufklicken kann und dann Clipboard, Clipboard ausmacht.
Das wäre natürlich enorm praktisch.
Noch mit irgendeinem Icon, dass ich es ordentlich erkenne.
Aber wir brauchen jetzt erstmal ein gescheites, gescheites
Mauszeiger-Theme.
Das sieht doch kacke aus.
Was ist, was ist ein gescheites...
Ich habe aktuell nur das Default, Default-Cursor-Theme.
Was gibt's denn?
Was gibt's denn für gescheite Cursor-Themes?
Irgendwas, was nicht ganz so, ganz so billig aussieht.
Kapitane-Cursors.
Wie sieht denn Kapitane-Cursors aus?
Ey, ist bestimmt irgend so ein Apple-Rip-Off, oder? Bei dem Name.
Kapitane-Cursors.
Okay, ja, es ist so ne, es ist ein bisschen Apple-Rip-Off.
Ist aber nicht schlimm, sieht ganz gut aus.
Probier was mal aus.
Ka, Kapitane-Cursors.
Ups.
Richtig schreiben wär ganz nice.
Starship-Themes.
Brauch irgendwas, irgendwas buntes.
Themes.
Resets.
Da gab's doch irgendwas, was Pastel... Genau, ja.
Kappa, Kappa-Pride-Font.
Äh, Kappa-Pride-Prompt.
Das ist ein pures Atsch.
Das ist doch mal was.
Das sieht tatsächlich ganz gut aus.
Wollt ich sagen, also ich muss...
Ich bin jetzt positiv überrascht.
Das sieht mit dem Farbschema von der Konsole auch gar nicht so übel aus.
Das da oben müsste jetzt halt, das müsste halt farblich noch dazu passen.
Das sieht aber gar nicht mal, vor allem mit dem Herzchen drin, und das sieht gar nicht mal so übel aus.
Behalte das.
Ja.
Sieht gut aus, ne?
So, Kapitane-Cursors.
Maus, Kapitane.
Hm.
Weiser Cursor oder dunkler Cursor?
Wahrscheinlich ist ein schwarzer Cursor gar nicht so schlau, weil ich hab ja überall ziemlich, ziemlich Dark-Theme.
Wir probieren mal, wir probieren es mal aus.
Also, wie sieht's mit, wie sieht's mit, wie sieht es mit schwarzen Cursors aus?
Bissi klein, oder?
Aber schwarze Cursor sind hier schon ziemlich schwierig drauf zu erkennen.
Ja.
Machen wir mal den weißen Cursor.
Bissi klein ist es auch.
Wir, wir machen das, wir machen das gleich mal ein bisschen größer.
Machen das gleich mal ein bisschen...
Okay, den Cursor sieht man DEUTLICH besser.
DEUTLICH besser.
Sieht man, sieht man.
Bissi klein ist es allerdings.
Ähm, glaub dazu muss ich...
Was machen wir mal für ne Size?
Also 32?
Einer muss ich jetzt immer dazu neu starten, dass das funktioniert.
Ja!
Das ist doch schon mal ganz gut hier.
Guck mal.
Das passt doch.
Guck mal, das sieht doch jetzt wirklich gar nicht so übel aus.
Das passt auch, guck mal.
Das...
Alter, guck mal wie gut das passt, Leute.
Die Höhe eines, einer, einer Zeile im Terminal ist exakt so groß wie das, wie das Select, wie das Select Cursor.
Als wär's, als wär's auf, es ist auf den Pixel genau fast.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es, glaub ich, gar nicht so gut.
Da sehe ich nicht, wo ich bin.
Wobei doch, doch, das ist gar nicht schlecht.
Ein bisschen, ein bisschen kleiner.
Komm, also eins kleiner, komm, machen wir, machen wir 30.
Falls das überhaupt geht.
Falls es nicht 32 so ein Default, so ein Default wird.
Nee, okay, das geht nicht.
Jetzt wird er kleiner, Cursor.
Schmoll.
Schmorder Cursor.
Linux, guck mal mal, was sind denn da so die Default Sizes?
Okay, Session is broken.
Linux Cursor Sizes 24, 32.
Okay, es gibt nur 24, 32, 48.
Ja.
Na, naja, okay.
Warum ist so was eigentlich nicht schlecht?
Nicht schon ein Vektor Font, äh, nicht ein Vektor Font, ein Vektor Bild.
So, seriously, warum ist der Cursor einfach noch nur in speziellen Größen verfügbar?
Warum ist der nicht Vektor Cursor?
Das ist was, das kann X wahrscheinlich nicht, weil, weil X muss ja den Cursor malen.
X ist wahrscheinlich zu alt.
Das kann keine Vektor Bilder malen und dementsprechend auch keine Cursor.
Aber das finde ich schon mal ganz gut.
Das hat was.
Da sieht man, da sieht man schon den Cursor hier im Terminal.
Hier ist es nicht so klein.
Das ist nice.
Und, und man sieht ganz gut auf diesem, weil ich, weil ich ja überall Dark Theme eingestellt habe, sieht man auch ganz gut den, hier einmal diesen Selector und dann halt hier oben halt den Cursor überall.
Wie bekommt man so Farben im Terminal?
Nutzt du das gleiche wie du?
Welche, welche Farben meinst du?
Das hier, äh, dass das Terminal insgesamt so aussieht?
Das hier ist mein Farbschema.
Du kannst aber auch einfach hier sowas laden.
Du, du kannst, du kannst auch einfach irgendwie ein Colorscheme laden, aber das, ach die Regenbogen, das hier, das hier, das ist Starship.
Starship RS.
Starship und das ist das, ähm, Preset Pastel Powerline.
Wobei man sagen muss, Starship ist eher was zum Selbstkonfigurieren, weil das hat nur.
Drei richtige oder vier, vier, vier richtige Presets.
Der Rest ist halt was mit Symbolen ohne Symbole.
Aber ich gehe davon aus, dass es wahrscheinlich auf GitHub ein bisschen mehr gibt.
Naja, also, ich meine nur, weil eine Software vor 40 Jahren erfunden wurde, heißt ja nicht, dass sie nicht mittlerweile angepasst werden kann.
Ich meine, es ist ja nicht so, als, als wäre X 40 Jahre alt, in dem Sinn, dass seit 40 Jahren keiner mehr dran was gemacht hat.
Ich meine, keiner hat Bock.
An X was zu machen, das kann ich auch verstehen.
X 11 programmieren muss wahrscheinlich abfakt des Todes sein.
Hätte ich auch wirklich keinen Bock drauf.
So, ich brauche mein Notizprogramm.
Ja, wobei, nee, nee, nee, nee, App Image brauchen wir.
Das App Image ist wenigstens.
Nicht mit Selbstkompilieren verbunden.
Wenn ich das hier installiere, dann muss ich bestimmt selbst kompilieren, oder?
Probieren wir gleich mal aus.
Man könnte ja auch ganz.
Five.
Mäßig das Bild von den Cursors einer Vektorgrafik je nach Größe gehen.
Ehe meine ich doch, du gibst an Größe 37 und dann ach so meinst du das.
Du meinst, dass der on the fly dann PNGs oder so draus macht, was das unterstützt.
Tja, das, das weiß ich nicht.
Guck, guck, guck, guck mal mal.
Ich kann euch übrigens noch was cooles zeigen, weil ich gebaut habe.
Gehen wir mal gucken.
User Share.
Wo sind denn die Cursor hier?
Cursor?
Nee.
Eggman minus QL.
Cursors.
Hier User Share.
User.
Okay, User Share Icons.
Kapitane Cursors.
Cursors.
Die gibt es gar nicht in unterschiedlichen Größen.
Was ist denn da was?
Ah, das sind alles, alles Links.
Okay, das skaliert X wohl irgendwie.
Und wenn X das skaliert, dann kann man da wahrscheinlich nichts dran machen.
X Cursor Sizes.
24.
Chal.
Sizes A 24.2.
Es gibt, seriously, es gibt ernsthaft nur diese.
Okay, Custom Cursor Sizes.
How to Enlarged Mouse.
Okay, das klingt schon fast nach Viagra Sperm so ein bisschen.
Exzellente Präsentation.
Alles klar.
Excellent.
Da weißt du Bescheid.
Ja, ja, ja.
Mhm, mhm, mhm.
Sowieso.
Verstehe, verstehe.
X Z Root.
Mein Gott, das ist wieder eine Wissenschaft für sich.
So einen Maus Cursor zu Resizen.
The default Exist.
Das ist ein Font.
Okay, das ist mir zu Six Head.
Das ist mir zu Six Head, den Cursor zu Resizen.
X Cursor.
Wie sieht so ein X Cursor im Source aus?
Yes.
Ah, obviously.
Hm.
Ja, wie?
Das kann das doch nicht anzeigen.
Auch kein loadable Image.
Was ist hier?
Kann VLC das?
Leute, wenn VLC das nicht anzeigen kann, VLC kann alles anzeigen.
Ich will.
Ich will das VLC.
Mein Cursor.
Anzeigt.
Nein, natürlich geht das nicht.
Oh, oh.
VLC ist der Meinung, das ist ein abspielbares Audio.
Ich glaube, so ein X11 Cursor Format verwirrt jede Software.
How to get available?
You can use X Cursor Viewer to look inside the cursor file and see what sizes are available.
Aha.
Okay, das ist Pfeife.
Das müsste man dann quasi.
Ich glaube, ich lasse das mit dem mit mit dem Custom Cursor.
Ich hätte den Cursor gerne ein bisschen kleiner.
Also Cursor ist okay, aber dieses Selection Ding hätte ich gern ein bisschen kleiner, weil das ist schon.
Das ist schon sehr fett dafür.
Na, X Cursor Viewer.
Okay, wenn es sowas nicht als Arch Package gibt, dann kannst du es, da kannst du es vergessen.
GitHub X Cursor Viewer.
Brauch man nicht.
Ich glaube, das lassen wir bleiben.
Bestes Cursor Seam Open Zone Cursor.
Zeig mal her.
Es ist der Wind.
Das ist der Windows.
Das sieht aus wie der Windows Zeiger, oder?
Also der Standard sieht ein bisschen aus wie der Windows Zeiger.
Ich bekomme ausbringen das Open Zone Open Zone Cursor Files.
Na, dann probieren wir mal aus, weil wir sonst nichts zu tun.
Die Pfeile sind zu klein und dick.
Gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir gleich mal erst mal kurz.
Erst mal kurz den Cursor selbst kompilieren.
So, äh, Icon Seam Cursor Seam.
Oh, was haben wir denn hier?
Black Slim?
Ah, guck mal, den gibt's den, den gibt's in PPGA, also in PPFAT und in nicht PPFAT.
Fire.
Ice?
Machen wir mal den.
Ich finde, das ist gar nicht mal so übel.
Close.
Das ist eins zu eins der gleiche.
Der sieht sehr Windows Mausig aus, gell?
Ja, das ist original die Windows Maus, Leute.
Der erzählt mir nix.
Das ist original die Windows Maus, Mann.
Und den gibt's anscheinend nur auch in einer Größe, hä?
Oxygen Cursors.
Warum sind das, warum sind die Dinge alle so alt?
Oh, ne, die kenn ich von früher noch.
Ne, die gefallen mir nicht.
Ich fand den, den ich vorhin hatte, gar nicht so übel.
Also, ich muss ehrlich sagen, den Windows Maus Cursor unter Linux, der verwirrt mich.
Dann hab ich lieber, dann hab ich lieber den anderen.
Weil das ist, das ist doch jetzt, das ist doch im Leben keine.
32er Size.
Äh.
Wir machen, wir machen wir das andere Cursor-Theme hier.
Kapitane.
Safe.
Open.
Zone.
Ne, wie hieß das Ding?
Cursor.
Ach du Scheiße.
Vergessen.
Ja, ach, X-Cursor.
X-Cursor Open Zone.
Excellent.
So, wieder alles weg.
Und noch einmal neu starten.
Und jetzt haben wir wieder den macOS Fake Cursor.
Das ist Arch, by the way.
Selbstverständlich.
Was soll's sonst sein?
By the way.
Natürlich, by the way, Arch.
Ach, wir lassen's jetzt einfach so.
Glaub, glaub, damit kann ich leben mit, mit diesem Cursor.
Wobei ich, wobei ich die Idee vom Ansatz her gar nicht so blöd finde, den gleichen Cursor zu verwenden wie unter Linux, äh, und wie unter Windows.
Dann hat man halt was, was Gewohntes.
Aber ganz im Ernst, ich hab's ja absichtlich so, dass es sich ein bisschen unterscheidet.
Also, es ist mir lieber.
Es ist mir deutlich lieber.
Also, das ist doch schon mal ganz nice.
Jetzt haben wir einen ordentlichen Cursor, jetzt haben wir ein ordentlich gesteamtes Terminal.
Ach, Leute.
Das Allerwichtigste.
Ganz vergessen.
Wo hab ich's denn?
Passt mal auf.
Das hier.
Das wichtigste Feature ever, was ich gefunden hab.
Ganz essentiell.
Transparenter, leicht transparenter Background.
Du, du, du, du, du, du.
So, und jetzt bräuchte man eigentlich noch ein bisschen Blur im Hintergrund, oder?
Das wäre, das wäre natürlich der richtige Premium.
So ein bisschen, bisschen Blur im Hintergrund.
Gehen wir mal hier.
Config pi com.
Wie macht man hier Blur?
Blur.
How to use transparency effects.
Jawoll.
Zeig, zeig mir, wie's geht.
Blur.
Alles klar.
Pepo ist geblurrt.
Bester.
Komm mal her.
Geblurrter Pepo im Hintergrund.
So mag ich das.
Ihr erkennt's wahrscheinlich gar nicht richtig.
Guck mal.
Jetzt ist er.
Da ist er.
Blurred Pepo.
Okay, das muss man machen.
Muss man auch setzen.
So.
Bester.
Bester geblurrter Pepo am Start.
Oh, jetzt ist das da oben auch geblurrt.
Das ist natürlich doof.
Wieso enden alle Lieblings-User immer bei Arch?
Ist doch gar nicht so.
Ist gar nicht so.
Manche enden auch bei Gentoo.
Ich glaube, das liegt daran.
Erstens, weil es ein Rolling Release ist und wenn man auf dem Desktop in Linux hat, glaube ich zumindest, dass viele Leute gut finden, wenn man die neuesten Packages hat und weil du es halt mit am besten customizen kannst.
Packages, Riesen-Software-Auswahl und Customizability würde ich sagen.
Wie kriege ich denn das Geblurrte da oben jetzt raus?
Guck mal, jetzt ist meine Leiste hier oben auch geblurrt.
Das ist natürlich doof.
P-Com exclude from Blur.
How to remove Blurred P-Com ads around Firefox.
Excellent.
Class Firefox.
Nee, nee, nee.
Das muss einfach angehen.
Remove Pycom Blur from Blank Doc.
Okay.
Blur Background exclude.
Blur Back...
Oh, ich bin im falschen Fett.
Blur, Background, Exclude.
Aha.
Siehste?
Ohne Scheiß.
Stack Overflow wieder.
Stack Overflow saved.
So, jetzt machen wir das zurück auf irgendwie 96 oder so.
97.
Und jetzt schimmert, guck mal Leute.
Jetzt schimmert der Pepo so leicht geblurrt im Hintergrund durch.
So ist das doch nice.
Guck, leicht geblurrter Pepo.
So, dass es nicht stört im Terminal.
Es ist eigentlich kaum zu sehen, aber wenn man drauf achtet, sieht man es.
So ist das nice.
Das gefällt mir.
Poggers.
Extrem Poggers.
Rainbow Poggers.
Das gefällt mir.
Das ist jetzt, das ist schick.
Nein, aber damit kann ich, damit kann ich leben.
Das lassen wir so.
Hm.
Also, wir haben ein Copy-Paste-Menü.
Die Schrift ist noch nicht ganz zentriert, da muss ich mal gucken.
Meine Notiz-Software ist jetzt auch drauf.
Oh, was ist das?
Wrong Case.
Warum ist die broken?
Was jetzt?
Moment.
Warum ist das?
Warum ist das broken?
Welchen Clip-Out-Manager?
Das ist Queen-Clip.
Weil das gute Rofe-Integration hat.
Warum, warum spackt das manchmal rum?
Hier, was ist da?
Kann ich das nicht einfach alles löschen?
Delete.
Yes.
Okay.
Irgendwas stimmt mit der Darstellung nicht.
Guck mal.
Moment, warte mal.
Notebooks.
Oh, Keckel.
New Note.
Ja, das ist kaputt.
Guck mal.
Irgendwas ist da kaputt dran.
Was ist da los?
Warum ist das broken?
Was soll das?
Was ist hier?
Also da ist irgendwas kaputt.
Auf jeden Fall gerade.
Vielleicht liegt es auch an der VM.
Aber ich habe es schon ewig auch in der VM laufen.
Guck mal.
Da ist irgendwas kaputt.
Mecker das Ding hier vielleicht?
Hat das irgendwas?
Das muss man bestimmt.
Muss man bestimmt GPU Acceleration deaktivieren.
Dann geht es wahrscheinlich.
Disabled GPU.
Turn off Hardware Acceleration.
Support.
Genau.
Oh, das ist immer sehr hilfreich.
This topic was automatically closed.
Geil.
Das ist immer super hilfreich.
Solche Feedback Foren, wo das Feedback einfach automatisch geschlossen wird nach 60 Tagen.
Hardware Acceleration.
Das geht bestimmt irgendwie.
Kann man No Sandbox oder sowas machen?
Vielleicht geht das dann.
Sandbox?
Das ist ja irgendein Chrome.
Oh, fuck, Alter.
Irgendein Chrome Problem.
Disable Hardware Acceleration.
Das ist bestimmt ein Elektron Problem in Zusammenhang mit dem Vm-Treiber.
Hier, guck mal.
Computer Screen Freezing.
Disable Hardware Acceleration.
Okay, ja, ja.
Wie, sag bloß, da gibt es nichts.
Da gibt es, seriously?
Es gibt keine Möglichkeit, die Hardware Acceleration auszumachen?
Ja, Elektron alleine bringt ja nichts.
Die müssen das ja supporten.
Die müssen den Kommandozeilen-Switch ja durchreichen.
Ja, das ist natürlich.
Das ist natürlich doof.
In meiner alten Vm funktioniert es aber.
Also, habe ich sie überhaupt hier installiert?
Genau, hier, by the way.
Guck, kein Problem.
In der alten Vm funktioniert es.
Ups, wenn ich das richtige Fenster nehme.
Alles okay.
Das muss irgendwas in Zusammenhang mit dem neuen Treiber und Vm-Wers sein.
Ja, okay.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
MonkaS.
Was jetzt?
Das habe ich ja noch nie geschafft, Vm-Wer zu crashen.
Also, läuft aber noch.
Easy.
Weil die Vm neu starten nach all den Änderungen.
Ich habe ja gar keine großartigen Änderungen gemacht.
Also, nichts, was irgendwie Grafikkart wäre oder so betrifft.
Okay, es gibt keine Möglichkeit.
Okay, ich habe noch eine Five-Header-Idee.
Da glaube ich aber nicht, dass dies funktioniert.
Aber man kann.
Man kann, vielleicht kann ich eine, ähm, hier, Linux Force OpenGL-Version.
Man kann, genau, man kann per Environment-Variable irgendwie, genau, sowas hier.
Man kann per Environment-Variable die OpenGL-Version runtersetzen.
Und vielleicht, wenn ich die OpenGL-Version runtersetze, dann rendert es noch, aber nicht in dem neuen Modus, der verbuggt ist im neuen Vm-Wer.
Das könnte natürlich sein.
Hallo?
Please laden, Seite.
Also, was haben wir denn?
Version 2.
Okay, wir nehmen, wir nehmen einfach mal das Älteste, was es gibt.
Export.
Gleich 2.
Ne, 2.
2.
Punkt 1.
Mal gucken, ob es dann überhaupt noch startet.
Startet noch?
Zeigt aber gar keinen Inhalt mehr.
Läuft eigentlich der i3 auf Tempo OS?
Selbstverständlich.
Was sonst?
Okay, mit so einer alten OpenGL-Version geht.
Gar nix mehr, alles klar.
Sehr gut.
Nice.
Was, was kann man als nächstes probieren?
Ich richte gerade meine Linux-VM weiter ein, Twinkor, und wir haben Probleme mit Rendering von manchen Anwendungen in der VM.
Wie sieht es denn mit OpenGL 3.0 aus?
Vielleicht geht es damit.
Ahhhh.
Ach, guck mal da.
Da gibt es jetzt auch keine.
Da gibt es auch keine Grafikfehler.
Easy.
Einfach alles in die OpenGL-Version runterstellen.
Okay, ab wann, ab wann fängt es?
Okay, 3.2.
Ab da geht es bestimmt los, kaputt zu gehen.
Ja, okay.
Da geht es kaputt.
3.2 geht es kaputt.
3.0 und 3.1.
Und so geht es anscheinend noch.
Excellent.
Gut zu wissen. Was haben wir sonst noch?
Compat.
Ah, LibGL-Always-Software.
Sehr gute Idee.
Unset.
Das wusste ich nicht, dass das geht.
Erstmal gucken, ob es jetzt wieder kaputt ist.
Ja, direkt broken.
Man sieht es glücklicherweise schon direkt beim Start,
wenn es broken ist, weil es dann irgendwelche
Farbfehler hier oben gibt.
Export und dann was?
True oder 1?
Oder was muss man da setzen?
Ach, nicht gleich 1.
Das funktioniert.
Wobei halt die Sache die ist.
Was ist besser?
Eine ältere OpenGL-Version setzen
oder generell auf
Software-Rendering forcen?
Letztendlich ist es egal.
Läuft beides.
Wahrscheinlich ist Software-Rendering
in dem Fall besser, falls
sie irgendwas Neues benutzen und das
mit der alten Version abkackt.
Die ältere Version sollte schneller sein.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber ganz ehrlich, bei dieser
Notiz-Software ist glaube ich nicht so das Problem,
dass ich die Performance,
den Performance-Impact so sehr spüre.
Zwischen Software-Rendering oder...
Komm, wir machen einfach so.
Easy.
So, tragen wir das mal ein.
Neues Shortcut.
Minus plus
J.
Jetzt.
Ich glaube, ich muss das erst so
Quoten, sonst wird das nichts.
Alles klar. Reload.
Error. Warum?
Wo ist das Problem?
Ist plus J schon belegt irgendwo?
Ah, change focus. Das brauche ich nicht.
Das mache ich mit den Pfeiltasten.
J.
Funktioniert.
Ach, das ist ja auch Desktop.
Aha.
Funktioniert.
Shortcut.
Zu. Shortcut.
Auf. Und ohne
Grafikfehler. Poggers.
Was ist eigentlich der Unterschied zwischen dem
App-Image
und Desktop?
Muss ich das hier selbst
kompilieren, dass es funktioniert?
Oh ja, muss ich. Nevermind.
Machen wir jetzt nicht.
Selbst kompilieren bei der Node.js-Anwendung
ist ja eh in Anführungszeichen.
Ne, dann nehme ich lieber das App-Image
und setze niedrige
OpenGL-Version. So, okay.
Jetzt kann ich Windows-Taste J drücken
und es geht mein Notizprogramm auf.
Nice.
So mag ich das.
So können wir das lassen. Was brauchen wir dann sonst noch?
Ich glaube, wir nähern uns so langsam aber sicher
der Vollendung.
Ach, ne. ZSH
muss ja umgeschaltet werden noch.
Ähm. Boah, das weiß ich nicht.
So.
Kann man das immer nicht merken.
ZSH. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. Massive Password.
Das macht man so.
Das macht man auch so. Das macht man einmal pro Installation.
Äh.
Create. Ja.
Create. Dings.
ZSH. Okay.
Github.files. Da muss ich
mal zumindest
die Basic-Sachen von der alten
ZSH rüberkopieren, weil das
alles mir neu ausdenken habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Wir werden aber die Hälfte
wahrscheinlich rauslöschen.
Also. Erst mal hier oben den Kabel.
Das ist gut. Das ist gut.
Das ist gut. Das ist gut. Das ist auch
okay. Prompt kommt weg. History
ist gut. Bin ganz bescheiden mit
der History. Kann man die History nicht auf 0
stellen? Dann ist es Unlimited.
Geht das nicht mittlerweile, dass man HistSize
auf 0 stellt und dann ist es
Unlimited History.
Ne.
Okay. Ja, das geht.
Aber HistSize 0 geht nicht.
In den Ansible Playbook.
Na, man kann es auch nicht.
Ja, aber. Ne.
In dem Fall. Hätte man schon machen können, aber
wozu? Maximum of
numbers. If this is my
life. It is not
implicit.
Hä? Das verstehe ich nicht.
Aber es gibt wahrscheinlich kein
Unlimited. Aber das reicht
auch. Ich meine das sind. Äh. Moment.
Wie viel 0? 1, 2, 3.
4, 5, 6, 7.
Also.
Eine Milliarde.
Ne.
10 Millionen.
10 Millionen Zeilen in der History.
Das ist in Ordnung.
Vielleicht kann das Thedas H auch.
Ich meine es wird praktisch gesehen keinen Unterschied machen,
ob 10 Millionen oder minus 1.
Aber wenn schon, hätte ich gleich minus 1
reingeschrieben, wenn das geht. So.
Das Shell Theme brauchen wir nicht.
Das brauchen wir auch nicht.
Das könnten wir mal lassen. Da weiß ich nicht mehr, was ich mir dabei
gedacht habe. Das schmeißen wir auch
weg. Ne. Top auf H.
Linken lassen wir da. Das da
brauchen wir auch nicht mehr. Das brauchen wir auch nicht. Das können wir
lassen. T-Mark verwenden wir an der Stelle
lokal nicht mehr.
Path brauchen wir auch nicht. Und das brauchen wir
auch nicht. So. Wir brauchen noch
unser Starship.
Und den ganzen anderen Krempel
nehmen wir mal mit.
Alias.
Zack. Bash.
I.
Ja. Okay.
Starship.
Äh. Prompt. Brauchen wir an der
Stelle nicht. Curl. Wetter.
Wunderbar.
Allerwichtigste überhaupt.
Ah, genau. Repo. Script.
Spin.
Sieht ganz sinnvoll
aus. Oh!
Was ist kaputt?
Habe ich irgendwo was mit
kopiert oder?
Zeile 45.
Ah.
Ja.
Okay. Kaum macht man es richtig,
dann funktioniert das auch schon.
Guck, der Pepo guckt uns zu im Hintergrund.
Da ist er. Da guckt er.
Der beobachtet uns. Genau.
So.
Jetzt habe ich so ordentliche Shell.
Jetzt drehe ich nicht mehr durch. Jetzt habe ich auch ordentlich
geshaerte History und sowas.
Bei Bash habe ich hier wieder den Anfall
gekriegt. Das musste jetzt wirklich mal sein.
So.
Notizprogramm launchen. Wunderbar.
Ähm.
Ich würde jetzt ja mein Joplin noch, also nicht
mein Rofi noch ein bisschen
weiter customizen, aber ich habe gerade echt
keinen Bock auf irgendwelches
Design
Kram hier.
Das muss jetzt erstmal so reichen.
Zumal
der Kram hier auch nicht richtig
aligned ist.
Was habe ich anstatt Bash genommen? ZSH.
Zisch.
Z Shell.
Kann man ja aussprechen, wie man will.
Ist mir viel angenehmer.
So. Ähm.
Dann lass mal überlegen.
Was brauchen wir noch für Dinger?
Clipboard.
Ach, wir könnten mal dieses
Autosuggestion
Ding ausprobieren.
GitHub
Autosuggestion.
Das da.
Gibt es doch bestimmt.
Outsook.
Gibt es als Package.
Und wie Insta. Exa habe ich schon installiert,
aber ich habe es noch nicht
irgendwie gelinkt oder so.
Oder alias gemacht,
bin mir noch unschlüssig,
ob ich es wirklich wieder verwenden will.
Was braucht man jetzt?
Source. Source. Irgendwie muss das gehen.
Source. Hier.
Zisch. Sings. Autosuggestion.
LSD.
Modern LS.
Okay.
Das hört sich jetzt nach
Monkatos an.
Next Gen LS Command.
Ist das denn auch Blazingly Fast
written in Rust?
Ich hoffe mal. Sieht so aus.
Okay.
Dann ist nice.
Dann probieren wir das auch mal aus.
Mit Icons.
Ah, und es ist direkt kompatibel
zu
zu den LS Befehlen.
Das ist nämlich bei Exa
ging mir das ein bisschen auf den Keks.
Das es nicht 1 zu 1 kompatibel
zu den LS Aliasen ist.
Kann man?
Ich gette, dass eines der Haupt
ein Haupt cooles Faktor
ist, dass das Ding
Terminal Icons hat.
Aber ich muss ehrlich sagen,
ich finde die Terminal Icons irgendwie
irritierend.
Chat.
Wir vergleichen das mal.
Was findet ihr im Default schöner?
Man kann das ja sicherlich konfigurieren.
Das da.
Wobei das ein Zerr ist.
Das muss ich in Bash machen.
Das da.
Oder.
Tja.
Kann man nicht machen jetzt.
Und meine Vor- und Zurück-Taste
geht auch nicht.
Also.
Ja, man erkennt es jetzt nicht richtig.
Hm.
Ich muss mal gucken, ob ich das irgendwie so hinkriege,
dass es nicht irgendeinen Pain gefokust hat.
Also das da unten ist
Exa.
Das ist klassisches LS.
Und das ist LSD.
Bad Game Musik.
LSD Easy.
Ihr könnt es euch ja mal kurz überlegen.
Ich muss mal ganz kurz pinkeln.
Ich bin wieder da.
Excellent.
Und?
Auf was haben wir uns geeinigt?
Was ist das Beste?
Also.
Ich muss sagen.
Die Ausgabe hier unten
sieht schön kompakt aus.
Und auch ganz gut formatiert.
Aber ich mag sie nicht.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich
Exa wieder runtergeschmissen habe.
Ich habe das ja auch vor ein paar Jahren mal angefangen
zu verwenden.
Der Grund, warum ich Exa wieder runtergeschmissen habe,
ist, weil es nicht
weil es LS zu unähnlich sieht.
Und ich bin einfach
LS-Output gewöhnt.
Und ich habe Remote auf Servern auch immer LS.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen,
mir gefällt das normale LS am besten.
Das da oben ist cool.
Die Farbwahl
ist vielleicht nicht so glücklich für mein Terminal.
Und
die Icons finde ich ehrlich
gesagt auch ein bisschen
overkill.
Ich meine, dass es ein Ordner ist, weiß ich.
Anhand der Farbe.
Da brauche ich kein Icon davor.
Und ob jetzt meine Dot-Files
seine Icon davor haben oder nicht.
Also.
Ach, wir können voten?
Okay, bin mal gespannt.
Ich glaube, die haben das alle nicht mitgekriegt.
Leute, die voten. Wisst ihr überhaupt,
was was ist?
Vielleicht hätten wir lieber 1, 2, 3 machen sollen.
Original Karat.
Hast du das Video geguckt?
Vermute ich jetzt mal
nach der Message.
3 ist Exa.
3 ist Exa, 2 ist LS
und 1 ist LSD.
Okay, die meisten Leute mögen LSD.
Das hört sich jetzt auch ein bisschen
verkehrt an.
Die meisten Leute mögen LSD.
Aber es bezieht sich
natürlich auf das Commando-Zeilen-Tool.
Okay.
Leute, seriously.
Mir gefällt das normale LS
fast am besten.
Also Exa schmeißen wir schon mal wieder weg.
Zumal das ja auch kein
Drop-in-Replacement
ist.
Also das normale gefällt mir tatsächlich am besten.
Also die Icons brauche ich
halt nicht.
Okay.
Was kann man da jetzt zum Beispiel einstellen?
Minus, minus, help.
Schon mal extrem
viel Zeug
kann man da einstellen.
One line.
Doch bei LSD immer so, oder?
Ja, kein Unterschied.
One line.
All haben wir.
Almost all.
Logs.
Ah, hier kann man angeben, was Display...
Finde ich schon ganz, ganz brauchbar.
Classify.
Was soll das machen?
Minus F.
Wo ist überhaupt der Unterschied?
Ah, ob es ausführbar...
Ne, hä?
Okay, was auch immer mir das Sternchen sagen soll.
Hyperlink to File Names.
Ach, dass man das anklicken kann, oder sowas?
Okay, minus H ist schon mal sehr sinnvoll.
Aber das habe ich ja schon angegeben.
Ach, guck mal, das kann direkt Recursive.
Okay, das ist natürlich nicht schlecht.
Icon, Icon Theme.
Guck ich mal aus.
Icon Theme.
Fancy.
Unicode.
Mein Font kann das nicht.
Dann bleiben wir wohl bei Fancy.
Wobei ich eher für Icons, Icons
Off.
Never.
Ja, das sieht doch schon gleich viel besser aus.
Das sieht doch schon gleich viel besser aus.
So, was macht Hyperlink nochmal?
No Waste.
Hä?
Ach!
Okay, ich muss sagen, das ist...
Der öffnet es jetzt in meinem Default...
Default Viewer dafür.
Das ist gar nicht mal so unpraktisch,
wenn du was öffnen willst,
in irgendeinem GUI oder so,
und willst nicht XDG Open
oder Zeug.
Wobei, ganz ehrlich, standardmäßig
ist es mir lieber nicht anklickbar.
Du bist auf Windows 11...
Ja, korrekt. Benutzt du 7-zip?
Klick das immer rechts an und geh über das Menü.
Du kannst...
Du kannst rechts anklicken und über das Menü sagen
Öffnen mit 7-zip.
Leider unter Windows 11 nur noch sehr umständlich.
Wie kann man die Farbe ausstellen
von den...
von den... von... hier...
den Zeiten?
Oder ist das nur, weil ich gesagt habe,
ich will nach Time sorten?
Ups. Hä?
Ach nee, jetzt habe ich wieder dieses komische Ding.
Dass...
dass mein Home und die Buttons
wieder in...
in Seller's Heart nicht funktionieren.
Es hat ein
config-File.
Warum nicht?
Wenn man da ein bisschen mehr drin machen kann.
config...
config-file-content
classic
Hier, theme.
Das kann man doch mit help auch.
Theme.
Icon-Theme.
Okay, man muss wirklich eine config anlegen.
Alter, ich brauche sie ja wirklich für jeden Scheiß mittlerweile.
Wo muss denn die config hin?
Ich glaube es nicht.
Ich konfiguriere meinen LS.
Source.
Theme. Was haben wir denn für Dinger dabei?
Colors.
Black, Blue, Dark, Blue.
Hat das irgendwelche default
Themes dabei, die man sich angucken
kann?
Oder gibt es da nur eins?
Achso, okay.
Die bringen nur eins mit.
Jetzt übertreiben sie es aber.
Jetzt übertreiben sie es aber, man.
Ja klar, man.
Wie bunt willst du dein Terminal
haben?
Also mir würde es ja reichen, wenn man
die Farbe ausstellen kann.
Also, Icons
muss auf jeden Fall weg.
Also, Icons...
Oh, das nervt. Warte mal.
Home
und End Key
not working.
Fixed Settings.
Da musste man, glaube ich, irgendwie
gucken... Okay, was für Key
Escapes gibt es denn?
F und H. Okay, danach kann man
nicht. Danach kann man... Fixed
Sysch in macOS.
Ja, genau sowas hier meine ich.
Genau sowas brauche ich.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Ich weiß nicht warum
Bash hat überhaupt keine
Probleme mit den Buttons.
Aber ZSH mag
nicht ohne diese Config.
Jetzt kann ich die Buttons verwenden.
Alle anderen Fenster und so, kein Problem.
ZSH denkt sich No Pass. Gibt es nicht.
Icon...
Was war es? Never.
Ja.
So sieht das eigentlich ganz gut aus.
Jetzt muss nur irgendwie die Color weg.
Ah, okay. Hier macht es
unformatierten Output.
Ja, okay. Das kann sein.
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Wahrscheinlich ist das so
wie du es sagst, Andreas. Aber ist das doof?
Dass das... ZSH
nicht interessiert, oder?
Oder warum wird es nicht mitgeliefert?
Die Color ist ganz gut.
Ich weiß nicht, ich finde das ziemlich...
ziemlich bloated.
Und ich habe auch keinen Bock für mein LS.
Muss ich euch ehrlich sagen.
Ich habe keinen Bock für mein LS
eine Config Datei anzulegen, Mann.
Und mir gefällt auch die Farbgebung
hier vorne nicht.
Also, ich glaube
ich bleibe beim ganz
traditionellen LS
Color.
Ich glaube, ich bleibe beim ganz traditionellen LS
und gut ist. Oder?
Weiß nicht.
Ich meine, wir könnten noch so eine
LS Color...
Dann sieht es... Installation...
Dann sieht es ein bisschen stylischer aus noch.
Das ist aber noch nicht
geladen. Wie lade ich das denn jetzt?
Pac-Man minus QL
LS Color
Shit. Das muss ich...
Muss ich das sourcen?
What the fuck?
Deer Colors.
Und Source
LS Colors Punkt LHSH
Das heißt aber nicht so.
Das heißt
einfach nur
so.
Der meint
Deer Colors wahrscheinlich.
Gehe ich mal von aus.
Okay, dann machen wir das jetzt mal.
Source
Und das hier oben zu den
Suggestions
Ach, das habe ich noch gar nicht hinzugefügt.
Das wollte ich nur machen
vorhin.
Okay, Source.
So, und jetzt haben wir jetzt nice Deer Colors.
Hey!
Boah!
Es wird ja immer bunter, Mann.
Seriously?
Leute, ich glaube
ich werfe das einfach wieder runter
und verwende stinknormales
LS und fertig.
Das braucht doch keiner.
Ich weiß
eh nicht, was die unterschiedlichen Sachen
bedeuten sollen.
Warum ist ein Ordner nicht einfach
blau, so wie ich es gewöhnt bin?
Es sind das
letztendlich... Irgendwo sind es doch Sachen,
die die Welt nicht braucht.
Source. Wir sourcen lieber
Pac-Man
minus QL
Auto-Suggestions
EXE habe ich auch probiert,
ja. Habe ich sogar noch da.
Ey, habe ich nicht.
Habe ich schon wieder aninstallt eben.
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen dem
und dem?
Source-Auto-Suggestions.
Toll. So, hier.
Source.
Und jetzt sollte ich theoretisch...
Ah, ich sehe schon. Guck
da mal. Aha, guck mal.
Jetzt kann ich das Auto
auto-complieten lassen.
Wenn es das ist, was ich haben will.
Mal gucken, ob ich
mich da dran gewöhne. Gestern hatte
irgendjemand, oder vorgestern, weiß ich nicht, vorgestern
muss das gewesen sein, hatte jemand im Stream erzählt,
wie geil das ist und er das immer verwendet.
Ich bin ja eher der History-
Surger. Also, anstatt
History zu searchen, könnte ich jetzt auch quasi
sagen,
äh, tap, tap, tap,
wie auto-complete man das eigentlich.
Also, außer, außer
mit Ende-Taste.
Gar nicht, gell. Suggestions.
Ja, was muss man denn drücken?
Complete?
Sind die vielleicht auch irgendwo
drinne? Usage. Hier.
As you will see,
this color kann
äh,
auto-suggestion-highlight-style.
Och, nö. Die Standardfarbe
finde ich eigentlich ganz angenehm.
If you press...
Ah, Moment, ich muss die
Pfeiltaste, ach, ich muss die
Pfeiltaste drücken.
Okay, ich kann Pfeiltaste drücken
oder End.
Ne, da will ich nix dran konfigurieren. Das ist okay
so. Kann man
so lassen. Ja, das finde ich
okay.
Ich prob... Leute, ich... Mal gucken.
Es schadet ja nix, mal was Neues
auszuprobieren.
An sich fühlt sich's mal ganz gut an, die Sachen
so auto-zukompleten. Die Sache ist
nur die, ist das Pfeifett
und lernt, was man öfters verwendet,
oder schlägt es einem immer nur das Letzte
vor? Wie macht das denn
...
Wie macht das denn
Phish?
Phish, das, was man zuletzt in diesem Directory
verwendet hat. Okay, probieren wir mal aus.
Downloads. Ach, ich wollte euch übrigens
noch was richtig Nices zeigen, was ich
gebaut hab. Guckt mal.
Passt mal auf.
Hier sind Bilder im
Verzeichnis. Und ihr wisst ja,
dass man mit...
Was haben wir uns das letzte Mal ausgemacht? ImageCat.
Kann man sich jetzt auch... Ups.
Kann man sich jetzt auch Bilder im Terminal anzeigen lassen?
So wie die
so wie die coolen Leute.
Und ich hab nen Alias gebaut,
guckt mal, der zeigt das Verzeichnis an,
wo man drin ist.
Alle Bilder.
Und es ist noch, es ist noch advancer.
Es ist noch, also er gibt da unten
das...
den Name vom Bild aus.
Also listet alle Verzeichnisse.
Und jetzt haltet euch mal fest, wenn ich
ein Verzeichnis auflisten lasse, wie zum
Beispiel User,
Share, Icons,
und dann hier das
Default Gnome Farbschema,
werdet ihr gleich folgendes feststellen.
Also erstens listet
er total viele Icons auf.
Aber guckt mal.
SVGs kann der auch
rendern.
Und ihr werdet feststellen, SVGs
kann westförmlich.
Das heißt,
wie kann das sein,
dass mein ImageCat
Faktor-Grafiken rendern kann,
wobei es das auch nur Fake-mäßig kann.
Und das ImageCat,
was eingebaut ist, nicht.
Passt mal auf.
Six Head Time.
Ich gucke erst mal, ob das ein Image ist.
Wenn es ein Image ist,
was mit SVG endet,
dann nehme ich FFmpeg,
skaliere das
hoch auf 640x480,
wandle das um
in ein PNG
und dann pipe ich es an westförm.
Dann lese ich mit westförm direkt das Image ein.
Das heißt, die SVGs,
die ihr da gerade gesehen habt, wurden eigentlich
on the fly in PNGs konvertiert.
Sodass es das wieder anzeigen kann.
Aber guckt,
jetzt kann ich Bilder
auflisten im Terminal.
Inklusive SVGs.
Das kann man sicherlich noch deutlich
cooler machen und verfeinern,
weil das ja nicht
SVG nimmt, sondern
ich habe zum Beispiel schon
eine Verbesserungsidee. Man nimmt nicht
die Endung, sondern man nimmt
File und guckt, ob
das ein
SVG Scalable Image
ist zum Beispiel.
Weil dann ist
die Chance nicht so groß, dass man irgendeinen
anderen Mist konvertiert, den man gar nicht konvertieren
will.
Aber so geht es erst mal.
Und jetzt kann ich
alle Images auflisten lassen.
Nicht, dass es wirklich großartig Sinn
machen würde, sich so ein riesen
verzeichnisrekursiv
Im Terminal
da irgendwie, guckt euch mal die
RAM-Auslastung an.
Da irgendwie im Terminal anzuzeigen
ist relativ unsinnig.
Gebe ich zu, aber es ist nice, dass es funktioniert.
Guckt mal, der RAM-Verbrauch.
Der RAM-Verbrauch geht richtig
ab. Fast schon 6 GB
verbraucht für sinnlose Bilder
im Terminal. Ach ja, und warum braucht es
so viel RAM? Naja, weil ich
jederzeit zurückscrollen kann.
Ich glaube, bald haben wir alles.
Du musst das
parallelisieren.
Du meinst, dass da irgendwie so
ein
Grid da draus macht?
Das ist natürlich ein bisschen
komplizierter. Musst du checken, wie breit
dein Terminalfenster ist und wie viel nebeneinander
passt. Wobei ich mir
gar nicht sicher bin, ob das
funktioniert, das im Grid zu rendern.
Kannst du schnell zeigen, wie man
Starship-Config machen kann?
Ja, kann ich machen.
So, guck mal, jetzt habe ich hier irgendwie 80
Milliarden Zeilen
Images.
Mal gucken, wenn ich Clear mache, ob er dann den RAM
aufräumt. Clear. Erstmal hängt
das ganze Fenster.
Blazingly Fast written in Rust.
Achso, ich hätte vorher mit Free gucken müssen.
Weil
RAM-Anzeige ist ja gar nichts. Das hier ist das
Entscheidende. Hätte ich vorher gucken müssen.
Ja, also Starship ist ganz einfach.
Du installierst Starship.
Falls du Anstellungs-Hast hier über das Package.
Starship.
Hast du wahrscheinlich schon gemacht. Dann gehst
du in deine Shell-Config und
trägst dort folgendes ein.
Je nachdem,
ob du Bash oder ZSH verwendest
oder Phish. Und dann
führst du
das eine Kommando aus, was da drinnen
steht und das war's dann. Dann geht's.
Dann suchst du dir hier irgendwie was raus. Das habe ich zum Beispiel
gerade. Und dann
kopierst du dir das hier und führst
es aus. Und dann updatet es
direkt deinen Prompt. Easy. Fertig. Mehr musst du nicht
machen.
Wenn ich jetzt irgendwas anderes kopiere.
Oh.
Dann ändert sich direkt der Prompt.
Easy.
Aber ich behalte den. Den finde ich nice.
Das ist alles. Mehr brauchst
du nicht. Kein
Oh my Z
Dingsbums. Ne. Das ist
bloated. Das ist
West Term. Genau.
Das beste Terminal, was ich seit Jahren
gefunden habe. Ich habe die ganze Zeit
letzten Jahre über Gnome Terminal verwendet.
...
Aber das wird ja nicht mehr weiterentwickelt und ich wollte mal
was neues ausprobieren. Das ist richtig geil.
Ich kann's, ich kann's wirklich jedem
nur empfehlen. Weil du kannst
deine komplette Terminal Config customizen.
Wie du willst. Kannst du gar dein Terminal
per Lua scripten.
Beste.
Poggers.
Massive Pog.
Ich kann jetzt ganz viele Terminals aufmachen.
Und dann durchscrollen. Ui.
Ui.
Dann kannst du wieder
zumachen. Nicht, dass
es jetzt Sinn machen würde.
Zeigt das Starship Theme auch an
in welcher .NET Version das Projekt
ist. Also
das hier macht es. Ob
das andere das kann, probieren wir
jetzt mal aus.
Also das hier macht das. So, jetzt machen wir das
andere. Preset.
Pastel Powerline. Äh.
Ne, tatsächlich. Das kann das nicht.
Das ist ein
besseres Starship Theme.
Wo hast du das her? Wo hast du das her?
Oder ist das
deins? Dein eigenes. Dein selbstgebautes.
Ach, du hast ein selbstgebautes. Komm. Komm, wir
gucken uns das mal zusammen an. Ich muss mal nur gucken, dass
da jetzt kein G-Bait drinnen steht oder so
bevor ich das ausführe.
Man weiß ja nie. Mal gucken.
Probier ich mal aus.
Ähm. Moment.
Wo muss ich das jetzt reinschreiben? Hier.
Ne. Config?
Ach, Moment. Ne, ne.
Alter, ich kann da tippen.
Config?
Starship Tommel.
Bam. Weirdchamp.
Du hast, du hast,
du hast Icons drin, die ich nicht installiert
habe. Wo denn?
Ich seh's jetzt gar nicht.
Ach, hier. Spack.
Spack.
Spack hab ich nicht installiert. Ich weiß nicht
mehr, was Spack ist. Äh.
Ist das nicht ziemlich
das Default?
Das ist doch so ziemlich das Default, oder?
Nur, dass du den Prompt
Das ist das Default Bracket Theme.
Nur, dass du den Prompt zur Uhr zeigst.
Also, wenn du die Uhrzeit gemacht hast,
seh ich das richtig, oder hast du sonst so irgendwelche Spezialanpassungen?
Ah, guckt mal.
Im Heimatverzeichnis zeigt es nur noch
ein Häuschen an.
Okay, das ist. Und Downloads hab ich auch gesehen.
Ja, und Desktop.
Downloads.
Ah ja. Ne, das mag ich nicht.
Weil dann kann ich den Pfad nicht kopieren.
Ist aber ne coole Sache. Find ich, find ich
ne gute Idee. Also, wir, wir
können's ja mal kurz versuchen.
Leko, hast du's jetzt hingekriegt?
Wir können's ja mal ganz schnell ver-
Oh, fuck, es ist 22.10, Leute.
Lull.
Eine Sache will ich mal ausprobieren.
Ich will mal hier .NET Configuration
für .NET reinmachen.
.NET, so.
Example.
.NET Symbol.
Das ist ein Fenster.
Das ist ein Fenster. Na, auch geil.
Okay.
Da kannst du mir jetzt aber mal kurz helfen.
Ne, ist .NET. Da kannst du mir mal kurz helfen.
.NET Symbol. Da kannst du mir mal kurz helfen.
Und, wie, du hast es nicht hingekriegt?
Warum? Das sind doch nur drei Schritte.
Ähm, muss ich das noch woanders eintragen?
Ach, hier muss ich, hier muss ich's
wahrscheinlich noch eintragen, ne?
Hier muss ich wahrscheinlich noch .NET
hinschreiben an der Stelle, dass es funktioniert.
Okay, Repos.
Moment, jetzt können wir das ausprobieren.
Repos. Ach so.
Okay, das ist doch ganz praktisch.
Und jetzt?
Steht doch nix von .NET.
Ich bin doch nicht im richtigen Ordner.
Ah! Reset?
Ne, ne, ne, ne. Lego, du musst das
nach, du musst das in diese Datei hier
pipen. Nimm das doch einfach von der
Homepage. Auf der Homepage steht doch drauf, wie's
geht. Guck mal, du musst
das hier runter, du musst das kopieren.
Das musst du eins zu eins so kopieren.
Dann legt es hier ne config-Datei
an, unter .config,
die Starship-Tommel heißt.
Und dann aktiviert sich's automatisch.
Wenn du's geladen hast.
Das ist ziemlich broken an der Stelle.
Oder? Oh!
Leute, mir fällt grad ein,
wir müssen dieses Theme noch etwas
tweaken.
Vielleicht nicht jetzt, weil
jetzt ist grad ein bisschen wenig Zeit.
Wie mach ich das Theme denn jetzt zweizeilig?
Ich mag
viel lieber zweizeilige Themes, weil
die dot files kommen auf GitHub, ja?
Weil guck mal, es ist ja hier kaum Platz,
wenn man sich hier viele Infos anzeigen
lässt. Ich will das
zweizeilig haben. Hast du hingekriegt?
Den Branch
kannst du auch kaum lesen.
Stimmt, stimmt.
Ja, muss man vielleicht noch ein bisschen die...
Ich glaube, das ist quasi zum
Tweaken gedacht, irgendwie.
Wie macht man das zweizeilig?
presets
github starship
äh
Wo sind denn
die Themes?
Weiß nicht, wo die Fall-Themes sind.
So,
dann machen wir mal presets und dann
faken wir das einfach mal, legen wir das mal hier daneben.
Presets
von Symbols, ja, wunderbar.
Weil das ist ja
das ist ja zweizeilig.
Oder machen wir...
Das weiß
ich, dass es zweizeilig ist.
Das ist pure prompt.
Pure
preset.
Ähm
Wie macht man das zweizeilig?
Format
Alter, was? Das sieht ja komplett anders aus.
Okay, das muss ich mir morgen
in Ruhe angucken. Das kriege ich jetzt nicht mehr gebacken.
Das muss ich mal...
Also ich...
Line break einfach.
Oder? Line break.
Einfach Line break an der
Stelle rein. Also quasi
äh, ja,
wonach? Quasi, quasi
nach dem Herzchen quasi, oder?
Time?
Machen wir mal hier Dollar.
Line break.
Äh, wenn man es da so richtig schreibt.
Hey! Okay, das sieht zwar
hässlich aus, aber von der Idee her ist
es doch easy.
Ja, das kann man noch ein bisschen tweaken,
aber das ist dann gar nicht so
wild. Ja, die Farbe muss man
noch ein bisschen anpassen. Das .net
mit dem Hintergrund sieht kacke aus.
Muss man sich noch was
überlegen.
Wir müssen einfach mal GitHub suchen.
Was da...
Das reicht für heute. Ich meine, es ist
guck mal, es ist fast komplett
nutzbar schon. Fast
komplett nutzbar. Überhaupt kein Ding.
Wir müssen es noch ein bisschen umformatieren
und der Rest ist eigentlich
soweit
fertig. Warte, ich kann ja
tippen. Ups.
Ah! Entfernen geht auch nicht.
Die Entfernen-Taste ist auch broken.
Warum? Entfernen.
Weil das Ding in der ZSH
fehlt. Ach, hier definiert
man den Background.
Scala.
Okay, Scala sollte ja einen Background haben.
Hier, guck mal, hier.
Style.bg. Okay, also
gehen wir mal .net.
Style.
Ups.
Style.bg.
Leute, ich habe es gebraked.
Ich habe es komplett
gebraked.
Aber warum?
Ah, ich habe zweimal Style.
Was ist das für ein
dummes File-Format?
Was ist denn
ein Tommel?
Was ist ein Tommel in den Kommentaren?
Ah, ja.
Boah, nee, das kann man aber nicht erkennen.
Das kann man nicht richtig erkennen.
Da muss ich die Farbe
noch ein bisschen anpassen.
Aber es ist fast gut.
Fast gut.
Die Farbe
kann ja wirklich keiner so lesen.
Also der Text
da drauf.
Ja, okay. Machen wir morgen weiter.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Morgen machen wir
nicht weiter. Morgen bauen wir an der Emulator-Kiste.
Die Schrift
in schwarz, ja.
Würde ich auch sagen, wenn man...
Ich muss mal ganz schnell noch gucken, wie man das
einträgt.
Schon von den Problemen der Samsung
90...
Nee. Samsung... Weil ich habe ja so
eine.
Report rapid health
degrade...
Degradation.
Vielleicht ist das auch nur ein Anzeigefehler, oder?
Oh, Round PC.
Muss man mal schauen.
Wie macht man hier den FG?
FG schreibt man da also hin.
Also kann ich jetzt hier einfach hinschreiben?
Wie würde ich jetzt dann
den... Ah, Leerzeichen.
Okay.
Also Leerzeichen FG.
Leute, ich kann es mir immer nicht merken.
Ist es FFFF oder
0000 schwarz?
Okay, das ist der Background?
00... Ah, nee.
Ja, jetzt erkennt man
das doch schon mal deutlich besser.
Weil jetzt...
Ja, ich muss jetzt ins Bett.
Hier.
Ich will mir noch die Schriftfarbe
rauskopieren.
Und zwar...
Foreground.
Alter.
RGB to...
Nee, Dings.
To Hex.
RGB to Hex.
Jetzt meine...
Was? 204?
204, 204.
So, was?
Excellent.
CCCC. Perfekt. Hätte ich immer gleich gewusst.
CCCC.
Das heißt, ich muss...
FG CCCC.
Nein. So.
CCCC machen.
Was ist jetzt schon wieder das Problem?
Achso, doch. Da muss doch noch eine Raute davor.
Das ist der Standard-Foreground hier. Der...
Der funktioniert ja nicht so gut.
Der funktioniert nicht so gut.
Also...
Vielleicht, vielleicht muss man den...
Vielleicht muss man das alles ein bisschen dimmen.
Jetzt aber gut.
Jetzt machen wir morgen weiter. Alles klar, Leute.
Wir sehen uns morgen. Bis dann.
Emulationskiste basteln. Bis dann.
Wir sehen uns. See you.